GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE AND
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US HERE
FOR THIS A JOINT INFORMATIONAL
HEARING WHERE THE COMMITTEE ON
WATER PARKS AND WILDLIFE AND
THE COMMITTEE ON AGRICULTURE-
ISN'T GETTING TOGETHER AB CHAIR
EDUARDO GARCIA FOR THE WATER
PARKS WANNA COMMITTEE AND
SHORTLY YOU'LL HEAR FROM CHAIR
ROBERT RIVAS THE CHAIR OF THE-
AGRICULTURAL COMMITTEE THIS-
HEARING WILL BE FOCUSED ON
DROUGHT AND ITS IMPACT ON
CALIFORNIA'S. AGRICULTURAL
INDUSTRY AND ITS ECONOMY-
BEFORE WE GET INTO THE AGENDA
WE WILL START OFF AS WE USUALLY
DO WITH A HANDFUL OF
HOUSEKEEPING COMMENTS-
REMINDING FOLKS THAT- THIS IS
THE- COMMITTEE THEY CAN
COMMITTEE AND- WE ARE STILL
OPERATING UNDER THE DEMICHELIS
WERE WE ARE LIMITING THE NUMBER
OF INDIVIDUALS THAT CAN BE
PHYSICALLY PRESENT IN THE
HEARING ROOM. TO ENSURE MEMBERS
OF THE MEDIA AND THE PUBLIC
HAVE ACCESS TO OUR PROCEEDINGS
TODAY. THERE ARE MULTIPLE WAYS
TO OBSERVE AND PARTICIPATE IN
THIS HEARING. MANY OF OUR
INVITED WITNESSES WILL TESTIFY
VIA VIDEO CONFERENCE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC MAY PROVIDE A COMMON
IN PERSON OR VIA TELEPHONE.
EVERYONE IN THE CAPITAL MUST
WEAR A MASK AND PRACTICE SOCIAL
DISTANCING YOU DON'T HAVE A
MASS WE CAN PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU
FOR ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
PRESENT IN THE HEARING ROOM
PLEASE FOLLOW THE DIRECTIONS OF
OUR SERGEANTS.AND POSTED
GUIDANCE IF YOU ARE PRESENT IN
THE ROOM AND WOULD LIKE TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY DURING THE
PUBLIC COMMENT PORTION OF THE
AGENDA. I WILL ASK YOU TO
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. WE WILL ALSO
BE USING A MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE THROUGH WHICH ANYONE
CAN PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT. AT
THE END OF THE AGENDA COLIN
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN AND THE
PIN IS TWO FOUR TWO SIX TWO.
THREE SEVEN. COULD ALSO FIND
THIS NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY
WATER PARKS AND WILDLIFE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AS WELL AS
ON YOUR TV SCREEN. PLEASE CALL
WHEN YOU HAVE HEARD FROM THE
LAST WITNESS. ON OUR AGENDA.
THE OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL
GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO
BE PLACED IN THE QUEUE YOU ARE
HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE
MODERATOR PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN
CALL THE COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE
SIX. THREE ONE NINE TWO ZERO
NINE SIX. I COMMITTEE STAFF
WILL BE THERE TO TRY TO HELP
REMEMBERS IF YOU WANNA MAKE A
COMMENT OR ASK ANY QUESTIONS OF
THE PANELISTS I REQUEST THAT
YOU WAIT. TO THE END OF EACH
PANEL TO DO SO. BEFORE WE
BEGIN. I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE IT
ASSEMBLY HAS EXPERIENCED A
NUMBER OF DISRUPTIONS TO THE
COMMITTEE. AND PROPERTIES IN
THE LAST FEW WEEKS. WHAT I MAKE
SURE THAT ALL VOICES ARE HEARD
HOWEVER WE ALSO WANT TO
CONDUCT- THE MEETING.
RESPECTFULLY AND MAKE SURE
THAT. THERE ARE NO DISRUPTIONS
AND THAT NO ONE DISTURBS. OF
THE PROCEEDING AS IT'S BEING
CONDUCTED. AND WE WILL MAKE
SURE THAT THAT TAKES PLACE
WARDINGLY NOW THAT WE'VE GONE
OVER HEARING THIS JUST TAKES I
WANT TO WELCOME OUR WITNESSES
TO THE HEARING AND THANK THEM
FOR COMING BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
TO DISCUSS HOW CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE IS BEING IMPACTED
BY THE CURRENT DROUGHT FOR
THANK MY COLLEAGUES SUMMARY WAS
FOR HIS INITIATIVE IN PUTTING
THIS HEARING TOGETHER ON THIS
IMPORTANT TOPIC. AS YOU ALL
KNOW WE ARE IN THE MIDDLE OF
OUR SECOND DRY YEAR IN THAT
ROLE AND ON TRACK TO SEE OUR
THIRD DRIEST YEAR ON RECORD.
WHAT STANDS OUT FOR ME THIS
YEAR IS HOW QUICKLY CONDITIONS
HAVE DETERIORATED WE KNEW WE
HAD A DRY WINTER BUT DUE TO
HIGHER TEMPERATURES THE SNOW
PACK AS EFFECTIVELY GONE BY
JUNE FIRST AND WE NEVER SAW AN
ESTIMATED EIGHT HUNDRED
THOUSAND ACRE FEET AND RUN OFF.
TODAY WE ARE FOCUSING ON THE
IMPACT OF DROUGHT ON OUR STATE
AGRICULTURE SECTOR. AGRICULTURE
IS CRITICAL PART OF THE STATE'S
ECONOMY AND OUR HISTORY. AND IT
IS FRIGHTENING TO SEE HOW THE
CURRENT DROUGHT IS IMPACTING
THIS IMPORTANT SECTOR. AND
DISRUPTING THE LIVES OF MANY
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES.
PUTTING THOSE IN OUR DISTRICT.
I LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING MORE
ABOUT THE PROBLEM AND WELCOME
IDEAS. ABOUT THE STATE NEEDS TO
BE WHAT THE STATE NEEDS TO BE
DOING TO RESPOND AND TO PREPARE
FOR THE DROUGHT. SO WE CAN
MINIMIZE ADVERSE IMPACTS.
THERE'S TOO MUCH AT STAKE NOT
TO TAKE ACTION WITH THAT I WILL
TURN IT OVER TO THE SOME RIVAS.
TO MAKE ANY OPENING REMARKS
THANK YOU ALL. WELL THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN GOOD AFTERNOON
COLLEAGUES IN I WANT TO THANK
CHAIRMAN GARCIA AND- THE STAFFS
OF BOTH OUR COMMITTEES TO PABLO
VICTOR WENDI AND NICOLE FOR
WORKING- AND PAULINE- THIS
HEARING- IN A VERY- BUT- THE
TIMELY MANNER YEAH THIS IS A
POINT HEARING- AS WE- WE
DISCUSS AND TALK ABOUT THE
IMPACTS OF OUR CURRENT DROUGHT
ON ON ON OUR STATE'S FARMERS OR
AGRICULTURAL OPERATORS IN AN
AGRICULTURAL LANDS. AND AS WE
ALL KNOW AGRICULTURE IS A
SIGNIFICANT SECTOR IN OUR
STATE'S ECONOMY A CONTRIBUTOR
ON FIFTY BILLION TO OUR STATE
ECONOMY IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN. AND GIVEN OUR UNIQUE
CLIMATE AS WELL AS THE
INGENUITY OF OUR FARMERS YOU
KNOW THERE ARE. SOME- SOME
COMMODITIES- YOU KNOW- MORE-
SOME COMMODITIES ARE GROWN HERE
IN IN CALIFORNIA THAN ALMOST
ANYWHERE IN THE WORLD AND THE
VAST MAJORITY OF THE
AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY. IS
COMPRISED OF SMALL IN SOME
FAMILY FARMERS WHO COOPERATE ON
SMALL AND TIGHT MARGINS. AND
ARE VERY- SOME VULNERABLE TO
EVEN SMALL FLUCTUATIONS WERE
TALKING ABOUT SOME SOME
FLUCTUATIONS AND PRICING CROP
OUTPUT IN OF COURSE THE
AVAILABILITY. OF WATER AND
DROUGHT FOR MANY OF THESE
FARMERS AND THE AGRICULTURAL
OPERATIONS IS NOT A TEMPORARY
INCONVENIENCE IT'S A
SIGNIFICANT THREAT IS A THREAT
TO THEIR LIVELIHOOD IT'S A
THREAT TO THEIR ABILITY TO PUT
FOOD ON THE TABLE FOR THEIR OWN
FAMILIES OWN KIDS AND THAT'S
WHY IS THIS YEAR HAS PROGRESSED
I'VE BEEN STARTING TO YOU KNOW
I'VE HEARD THE CONCERNS THAT
MOUNTING SOME CONCERNS BY
FARMERS UP AND DOWN OUR OUR OUR
STATE. WHO ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE MAGNITUDE OF THIS CURRENT
DROUGHT. AND THE IMPACTS ARE
ALREADY FILLING AS A RESULT OF
IT MANY WHO HAVE LACKED ACCESS
TO WATER ALREADY OR ARE OR IN
ANTICIPATION OF IT HAVE MADE
SOME SIGNIFICANT REDUCTIONS IN
PLANTING CROPS OR HAVE MADE
CUTS IN THEIR PRODUCTIONS THIS
GROWING SEASON IN THE CURRENT
DROUGHT IS ALREADY THE MOST
SEVERE SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT IT COMES JUST TWO YEARS
AFTER THE LAST DROUGHT RAVAGED
FARMS FROM TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN. THEY
GIVEN THE STARKEST ELLERY
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE THIS
YEAR'S DROUGHT CAN ONLY BE
EXPECTED TO BECOME A MORE
COMMON OCCURRENCE. IN FACT
SCIENTISTS SAY THAT DUE TO
CLIMATE CHANGE THE AMERICAN
WEST IS DRIER THAN IT HAS BEEN
IN TWELVE HUNDRED YEARS OUR HOT
AND DRY. IS YOU KNOW IS
UNFORTUNATELY THE NEW REALITY
FOR OUR FARMERS FOR RESIDENTS
OF THE STATE. AND THEY NEED OUR
SUPPORT YOU KNOW WE MUST DO ALL
WE CAN ASK POLICYMAKERS TO
UNDERSTAND THIS EVOLVING
SITUATION OR THESE CONDITIONS.
AND WORK TOGETHER. WORK
TOGETHER TO ADJUST TO THIS NEW
REALITY AND THOUGH THE DROUGHT
HAS THUS FAR MOST SIGNIFICANTLY
IMPACTED FARMS ON THE NORTH
COAST AND IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
FARMERS IN THE SENATE DISTRICT
I REPRESENT ARE STRUGGLING AS
WELL AS THE SALAD BOWL THE
WORLD FARMS AROUND THE SALINAS
VALLEY AND WATSONVILLE IN
SEMINOLE COUNTY THEY DEPEND ON.
INEFFICIENT AND SUSTAINABLE
STORAGE OF WATER- LONGER WAIT
YEARS- AND THEY DO THIS TO GET
US THROUGH OUR DRYER YEARS-
JUST RECENTLY I VISITED THE
NACIMIENTO AND ST. OR THE U. S.
SENATE TONIO DAMS IN THE COUNTY
MONTEREY. AND THIS TRIP WAS EYE
OPENING THE SEEN FIRST HAND HOW
BOTH RESERVOIRS ARE AT
CRITICALLY LOW LEVELS.
NASCIMENTO'S AT 40% CAPACITY.
SAN ANTONIO AT 7% CAPACITY
THAT'SUNBELIEVABLE 70%
CAPACITY. AS A RESULT WATER-
SOME RELEASES FROM THESE
RESERVOIRS TO HELP RECHARGE
AQUIFERS AND- AND HELP. PREVENT
SEAWATER INTRUSION IN OUR
REGION- STOPPED TWO POINT FIVE
MONTHS AHEAD OF SCHEDULE. WHICH
MEANS NO WATER WILL BE RELEASED
IN AUGUST SEPTEMBER OCTOBER OF
THIS YEAR NOW I ALSO RECENTLY
VISITED SMALL FARMS AND- IN OUR
DISTRICT- INCLUDING THE TARA
MIKO ORGANIC FARM IN SAN
MARTINE IN. THE SOUTHERN PART
OF SANTA CLARA COUNTY. THEY
GROW SOME TOMATOES AND A
VARIETY OF OTHER AND
VEGETABLES. I WAS IMPRESSED AT
THE RESILIENCE- ANY EFFORTS
THAT THEY HAVE MADE TO CONSERVE
WATER- YOU KNOW BYE BYE-
INCLUDING THE UTILIZATION OF
DRIP IRRIGATION TECHNIQUES IN.
THE ROTATION OF CROPS. BUT
WHILE THE- THE SALINAS IN THE
BOROUGH VALLEYS MAY HAVE ENOUGH
WATER TO LAST THIS SEASON.
WE'RE CERTAINLY ALL WORRIED
ABOUT THE TOUGH DECISIONS
GROWERS WILL NEED TO MAKE NEXT
SEASON AND IN THE YEARS AHEAD.
TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE ABLE TO
FEED NOT ONLY OUR STATE BUT THE
REST OF THE NATION. AND THAT'S
WHY I'M GRATEFUL TO HAVING THIS
DISCUSSION HERE THIS AFTERNOON
AS WE FACE WHAT. COULD BE
ANOTHER SEVERAL YEARS OF
DROUGHT WE MUST LOOK AT WHAT
ACTION WE CAN TAKE THIS POLICY
MAKERS IN THE NEAR AND LONG
TERM TO ENSURE OUR STATE'S
FARMERS CAN REMAIN RESILIENT.
TO DROUGHT- AND TO ASSURE OUR
LIMITED WATER SUPPLY IS USED
EQUITABLY AND RESPONSIBLY.
AGAIN LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING
FROM OUR PANEL TODAY AND AGAIN
WANT TO THANK OUR COLLEAGUES
WHO ARE HERE AND THINK CHAIRMAN
GARCIA. FOR HELPING ORGANIZE
THIS YEAR I THINK THANK YOU A
THREE OF US AND- WE HAVE OUR
FIRST PANEL IT. AND BELIEVE IS
READY TO GO J. LEARNED
PROFESSOR AT. UC DAVIS CENTER
FOR WATERSHED SCIENCES SECTOR
KAREN ROSS PARMON OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE AND OPTIMISTIC
ABOUT CHAIRS STATE WATER
RESOURCES BOARD BOTH ALL THREE
OF THEM WILL SPEND ANYWHERE
BETWEEN EIGHT AND TEN MINUTES
TO- PROVIDE THEIR
PRESENTATIONS. AND THEN WILL- A
PAUSE FOR IT QUESTIONS. AND
ANSWERS FROM- THE BODY HERE SO
WITHOUT FURTHER ADO WE'LL START
WITH- PROFESSOR J. LINE IF
HE'S- SHE'S READY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ALL CAN YOU ALL HEAR
ME WE CAN HEAR YOU THANK YOU-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
INVITING ME HI FOR THIS AUGUST
PADDLE AND- SOME ALL ASSEMBLY
WATER COMMITTEE WATER AND I
CALLED HER COMING I WANT TO
MAKE SOME VERY BRIEF REMARKS
TO. BASICALLY SUMMARIZED
WITHOUT CONDITIONS SOME OF
WHICH IS ALREADY A MEMBER OF
THE PREVIOUS SPEAKER AND THEN
TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE
APPLICATIONS I'LL TRY TO BE
BRIEFED OF REPORT TIME FOR TWO
ONE DAY SINCE. WE'VE STARTED
LIKE LATE R. CALIFORNIA HAS A
LONG HISTORY OF DROPS AND IT'S
CLIMATE IS INHERENTLY I FELT
PRO WE HAVE A LOT OF VERY
ABILITY. ITSELF ACTUALITY IN
CALIFORNIA HAS SOME OF YOU ARE
PROBABLY QUITE AWARE WE HAVE
MORE FLOOD YEARS AND DROUGHT
YEARS FOR EVERY YEAR THAN ANY
OTHER STATE OF THE UNION THAT
MEANS WE ARE ALWAYS HAVING TO
WORRY ABOUT- DROUGHTS AND
FLOODS AT THE SAME TIME SO
WE'RE WE'RE ALWAYS TRYING TO
MANAGE TO WORK TOGETHER UP
WATER AND WHAT YEARS AND
STARTED RESERVOIRS AND AQUIFERS
FOR DRY YEARS. WERE TRYING TO
MANAGE AGRICULTURE THIS CASE
FOR BOTH OF THE DRY YEARS AND
FOR FLOOD SO WE INVEST A LOT OF
LEVEES AND WE INVEST A LOT OF
WATER MANAGEMENT. OVERALL IT'S
BEEN A CONSTANT- OVER A HUNDRED
FIFTY YEARS OF CALIFORNIA'S
STUFF HELLO ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT YOUR THIS YEAR AS
WAS MENTIONED AS THE THIRD
DRIEST YEAR AND MORE THAN A
HUNDRED YEARS OF SUFFOCATION
RECORD IT FOLLOWS ON LAST YEAR
WHICH WAS A LYFT DRIVERS TO
YOUR THE PRECIPITATIONARCTIC
SO. TO VERY DRY YEARS WITH THIS
YEAR BEING EXTRAORDINARILY IN
ADDITION TO THAT THE
TEMPERATURES HAVE BEEN MUCH
WARMER AND SO THE PRECIPITATION
DOESN'T GET AS FAR ALL THE
PRECIPITATION EVAPORATES BACK
UP INTO THE ATMOSPHERE BEFORE
IT CAN MAKE ITS WAY INTO A
STREAM INTO A RESERVOIR WATER
RECHARGING AQUIFERS THIS IS
ESSENTIALLY THE CHARACTERISTIC
OF THE MODERN DROUGHT THIS
DROUGHT OF THE ONE FROM TWENTY
TWELVE TO TWENTY SIXTEEN BOTH
WERE. MUCH WARMER CONDITIONS
ONE I THINK WE'RE GOING TO SEE
THAT IN THE FUTURE. THERE'S
SOME INTERESTING TALKING THE
LITERATURE THAT DEMONSTRATES
PRETTY CLEARLY THAT THOSE
HIGHER RATES OF EVAPORATION
MAKES SMALL DROUGHT IN THE
BIGGER DROUGHT AND SO WE'RE
GOING TO POTENTIALLY FROM THERE
SEEING. LONGER AND MORE
FREQUENT DROUGHTS THAN WE HAVE
SEEN OTHERWISE IN ADDITION TO
WHATEVER CHANGES OF
PRECIPITATION PATTERNS WE MIGHT
SEE WITH CLIMATE CHANGE IS THE
INCREASE IN TEMPERATURES ARE
REDUCING THE AMOUNT OF WATER
WAS AVAILABLE TO US THIS
REDUCED ABOUT OF WHAT IS
AVAILABLE TO US IN THIS DROUGHT
BECAUSE OF COURSE AFFECTING THE
SURFACE WATER AVAILABLE FOR
AGRICULTURE ESPECIALLY IN THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY TOMORROW
GRAYSON BUT ALSO IN PARTS OF
THE SACRAMENTO VALLEY AND THE
SMALLER REAL OF THE RIVER
VALLEYS ABOUT- NAPA VALLEY AND
SONOMA- RUSSIAN RIVER AMONG THE
OTHER BASINS OF THE STOCK IS
THIS DROUGHT IS PRETTY PRETTY
EXTENSIVE COVERING THE ENTIRE
STATE OF BIRTH OTHER PART OF
THE CENTRAL VALUES WAS MUCH
MORE DROUGHT PRONE BECAUSE IT
RELIES MUCH MORE ON IMPORTED
SERVICE WATER. BURGER ALSO
RIDICULOUS I HAVE ALSO BANNED
AS YOU'VE PROBABLY HEARD MAJOR
IMPACTS ON FOREST AND AQUATIC
ECOSYSTEMS INCLUDING THE LOSS
OF WHAT AROUND SALMON FELL
SCREAMO SHASTA DAM. AND WE'RE
SEEING OUR EXPANDED WILDFIRE
IMPACTS WILDFIRE SEASON.
COMFORTING THE ADDITIONAL
PUMPING OF GROUNDWATER THAT'S
HAPPENING BECAUSE OF REDUCE
SERVICE WATER SUPPLIES FOR
AGRICULTURE YOU'RE SAYING
BROUGHT OUT OF WORLD
GROUNDWATER TABLES ONE THAT'S
AFFECTING RURAL HOUSEHOLD WELLS
AND SMALL COMMUNITY WELL SO WE
HAVE QUITE A LOT OF SMALL
PARTICULARLY POOR COMMUNITIES
THAT ALREADY HAVE SHALLOW
WELLS- BEING VULNERABLE TO
THESE KIND OF ATTACKS WHAT
COULD BE EXPECTED TO INCREASE.
BY NEXT YEAR TO REMAIN STRONG.
NEXT YEAR IS ALSO DRY ALL THE
IMPACTS TO AGRICULTURE THE
ENVIRONMENT AS WELL AS
INCREASING IMPACTS URBAN AREAS
SMALL TOWNS WERE AFFECTED. THIS
YEAR AND MORE LARGER STUDIES
COULD BE AFFECTED NEXT YEAR ALL
WILL BE WORKS THE WARMER
TEMPERATURES CLIMATE OR
WORSENING DROUGHT BOB AND
REDUCING THEIR INCREASING THE
AMOUNT OF WATER THAT HAS TO BE
RELEASED TO PROVIDE COLD WATER
FOR NATIVE COLD WATER FISH
DURING THE DROUGHT SO WE'RE-
PROVIDES QUITE A LOT OF
CHALLENGES. NEXT YEAR IS MORE
THAN USUALLY LIKELY TO NEED TO
BE DRY THIS YEAR WE HAVE A VERY
DRY WATERSHEDS WE HAVE GREATLY
DEPLETED RESERVOIRS AS THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKER MICHAEL OUR WE
HAVE WATER TABLES WHICH ARE NOW
MUCH LOWER WHAT'S THE WARMER
TEMPERATURES THAT WILL INCREASE
ABOUT FOUR TRANSPORTATION
BECAUSE WE LOOK FORWARD SO IT'S
GOING TO TAKE MORE
PRECIPITATION TO MAKE NEXT YEAR
WET. I DON'T NORMALLY WOULD
TAKE SO IT MAKES IT MORE LIKELY
THAT WE'RE GOING TO HELP US
ROUTE YOUR THAT WOULD REFORM
FOR THOUSANDS TO PREVIOUS
PRIVATE I'M NOT A BIG CHANGE
BROADER CULTURE I THINK IN THIS
DROUGHT RIVAS RELATIVES HOWEVER
CULTURE TENDS TO MAKE UP ABOUT
TWO THIRDS OF ITS WELL DEFICIT
BY PUMPING IT IS MORE
GROUNDWATER WHAT THE
SUSTAINABLE GROUNDWATER
MANAGEMENT ACT THAT WATER IS
GOING TO HAVE TO BE REPAID THE
PASSED AWAY JUST WHAT CUMULATE
AS LAND SUBSIDENCE. FROM WATER
OVERDRAFT BUT WHEN YOU'RE A
STABLE GROUNDWATER MANAGEMENT
ACT. THAT WATER IS GOING TO
HAVE TO BE REPAID IN WATER
YEARS. BY MOSTLY BY REDUCING
GROUNDWATER PUMPING WHICH IS
GOING TO BE. REDUCING YOUR DATA
COLLECTION THE LONG TERM. WE
CAN EXPECT TO SEE PROBABLY HALF
A MILLION TO A MILLION ACRES OF
IRRIGATED LAND OUT OF
PRODUCTION IN THE LONG RUN.
JUST TO ACCOMMODATE THE ENDING.
OF OVER THE TOP OF THE SITE.
SOME OF THE OTHER BIG THINGS
THAT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO SEE
HOW LONG WITH A- ALL PRIOR YEAR
MIGHT. OCCUR THIS COMING YEAR
THERE'S ADDITIONAL URBAN WATER
CONSERVATION WHICH HELPS A
LITTLE BIT. BUT GIVEN THE
RELATIVE MAGNITUDE MUCH GREATER
MAGNITUDE OF BOB WATER USE
AGRICULTURE THAT URBAN AREAS IT
ONLY HELPS A LITTLE BIT WHAT WE
WILL PROBABLY HAVE TO SEE NEXT
YEAR CONTINUES TO BE DRIEST
EXPANSIONS OR LAND IDYLLWILD
WELL MOSTLY FROM LOWER VALUE
CROPS WILL HAVE REDUCED
ECONOMIC IMPACT PROBABLY THE
THING THAT THE STATE NEEDS TO
DO MOST TO PREPARE US TO HAVE
THESE MORE FREQUENT AND MORE
SEVERE DROUGHTS OF THE FUTURE
I'M TO KEEP AGRICULTURAL
PROSPEROUS THROUGHOUT THOSE
KIND OF EXTREME ABOUT. IS TO
HAVE A MUCH MORE FORMAL. OUR
WATER ACCOUNTING SYSTEM
STATEWIDE ACROSS THE STATE
AGENCIES THESE ARE NEEDED TO
HEIGHTEN SERVICE WATER RIGHT
MINISTRATION HOWEVER WHAT DOES
HOW MUCH WATER THEY HAVE. FOUND
USEFUL FOR SIGMA PLANNING AND
IMPLEMENTATION AS WELL AS
ENVIRONMENTAL WATER MANAGEMENT.
ESPECIALLY IN THE FUTURE WE'RE
GOING TO SEE WATER RIGHT
CURTAILMENTS BECOME MUCH MORE
TEETH SO THOSE. WATER RIGHT
CURTAILMENTS ARE GOING TO BE
MIRRORED YEAH RETIREMENTS AND-
ALL GROUNDWATER AVAILABILITY ON
THE SHIP ALL RIGHTS RESERVED
THE END OF MY REMARKS ON DAHLE
WE LOVE SOMETIMES WHAT YOU AND
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU SIR WE'RE GOING TO ASK OUR
SECRETARY ROSS NOW TO BEGIN HER
PRESENTATION. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARDS YEAH AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REQUESTS ARE HOLDING THIS
HEARING IN INVITING ME TO BE
HERE- IT'S NOT FUN TO FOLLOW
THAT KIND OF SOBERING NEWS FROM
JAKE LAND BUT THAT'S NOTHING
COMPARED TO THE PAIN THIS THING
FELT WITHIN A REAL COMMUNITIES
ARE FARMING FAMILIES AND BY THE
FARMWORKERS WHO DEPEND ON MANY
OF THOSE ANNUAL CROPS THAT
WERE. PLANTED AND IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT THAT WE KEEP IN MIND
THE WHOLE COMMUNITY THAT'S
IMPACTED BY THIS DROUGHT- BUT
THAT THAT CIRCUMSTANCES WE FIND
OURSELVES IN ARE UNAVOIDABLE
AND THE SET UP HERE IS SUCH
THAT I WON'T TAKE A LOT OF TIME
TO BE ABLE TO DISCUSS. WHAT
MAKES CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE SO
UNIQUE OTHER THAN WE ARE THE
PRODUCER OF A WIDE VARIETY OF
FRUITS AND NUTS AND DAIRY
PRODUCTS AND VEGETABLES AND
PROCESSING TOMATOES AND ALL
THOSE THAT ARE VERY IMPORTANT
TO NUTRITION AND FOOD SECURITY-
AND WE DO IT BETTER HEAR MORE
EFFICIENTLY HERE ARE WITH A
STRONGER COMMITMENT TO
ENVIRONMENTAL AND LABOR
STANDARDS THAN MOST ANY OTHER
STATE IN MANY OTHER COUNTRIES.
AND SO IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
FIND WAYS TO WORK TOGETHER- I
AM VERY THANKFUL THAT YOU'RE
INCLUDING SEVERAL PANELS OF
OURS BECAUSE I THINK IT'S MOST
IMPORTANT WHEN WE THINK ABOUT
THE IMPACT THAT WE HAVE THE
PEOPLE WHO MOST DIRECTLY
IMPACTED. TO HEAR THEIR IDEAS
AS WE WORK TOGETHER TOO CUTE
MEDICATION WHEREVER IT'S
POSSIBLE TO TRY TO LESSEN THOSE
PACKAGE GIVE ME THE ECONOMIC
IMPACTS THAT ALSO WORK TOGETHER
FOR THE LONGER TERM SOLUTIONS
MEDITATES ON A COUPLE OF
PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE BEEN
BUILDING SINCE THE LAST DROUGHT
TO INCREASE THE RESILIENCY OF
AGRICULTURE. THEY'RE CREATED AS
PART OF OUR CLIMATE SMART
AGRICULTURAL PROGRAMS AND
THANKS TO YOUR WORKING WITH THE
GOVERNOR SEVERAL OF THOSE HAVE
RECEIVED CURRENT YEAR FUNDING
IN THIS BUDGET ACT THAT WAS
PASSED- AT THE END OF JUNE AND
WE'RE VERY HOPE THAT AS YOU TO
GET WITH THE ADMIN ON THE
ENTIRE POINT ONE BILL DOLLARS
RESILIENCY AND CHAT WITH
PACKAGE THAT WILL BE ADDITIONAL
PROGRAMS THT ARE FUNDED. IN
PARTICULAR I WANT TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT OUR ON FARM
WATER USE EFFICIENCY PROGRAM.
WAS CREATED IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
WE HAVE FUNDED OVER EIGHT
HUNDRED PROJECTS- ACROSS THE
ENTIRE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE
ARE COMMITTED TO FUNDING AT A
MINIMUM 25% OF OUR PROJECTS
THAT WILL GO TO. SOCIALLY
DISADVANTAGED FARMERS AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES TO
IMPROVE THEIR RESILIENCY WE
HAVE INVESTED EIGHTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO DATE THE BUDGET
THAT. WAS APPROVED- DOESN'T TO
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS TO ADD TO
THAT PROGRAM. IT ALSO FUNDS
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AS WELL AS
DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS AS WE
SCALE UP THE MOST EFFICIENT USE
OF EVERY DROP OF WATER
POSSIBLE. OVER THE LIFETIME OF
OUR SWEET PROGRAM WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO REDUCE OUR GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS. BY HUNDRED AND
SEVEN THOUSAND. METRIC TONS-
BUT THIS IS A WIN WIN PROGRAM
NOT ONLY REDUCES GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS BECAUSE WE'RE
IMPROVING OUR ENERGY EFFICIENCY
WE'VE ALSO BEEN ABLE TO SAVE.
ALMOST A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
THOUSAND ACRE FEET OF WATER
THROUGH THE USE OF THE MOST
PRECISE TECHNOLOGY BUT HOW WE
USE WATER. THAT'S THE
EQUIVALENT OF THIRTY SEVEN AND
A HALF BILLION GALLONS OF WATER
WHICH WOULD STILL SEVENTY
OLYMPIC POOL I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO PUT THAT INTO-
THAT KIND OF THE CONTEXT- WE
ALSO RECEIVED FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR A NEW TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. THAT
SPECIFICALLY WORKING WITH
GROWERS OF ALL SIZES IN ALL
PARTS OF THE STATE WITH MOBILE
IRRIGATION LABS TO BE ABLE TO
CONTINUALLY IMPROVE. OPTIMIZE
THE USE OF OUR WATER.
IRRIGATION SYSTEMS ARE MAKING
SURE THAT THE PUMPS ARE
OPERATING AT MAXIMUM CAPACITY
AND THE MOST ENERGY EFFICIENT
WAY BUT THE DRIP LINES ARE ALL
CLEARED IN THAT WERE. ABLE TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS ON HOW TO
IMPROVE THE EFFICIENCY OF THE
SYSTEMS THAT WE HAVE ON THE
GROUND. WE ALSO HAD TWO MILLION
DOLLARS TO CONTINUE THEIR
OUTSTANDING WORK THAT I KNOW
THAT. YOU'LL HEAR ABOUT LATER
IN THE LAST COUNT TO BE ABLE TO
CATCH WHAT THE AND ARE IN EACH
DROUGHT WHAT IT MEANS FOR JOB
LOSS WHAT IT NEEDS FOR
FOLLOWING WHAT IT MEANS FOR
ECONOMIC LAST- AND THIS YEAR I
AM VERY EXCITED THAT WITH THE
GOOD WORKING LED BY SEE MORE
SAD WILL ALSO BE CREATING SOME
SUPPORT DECISION TOOLS TO HELP
GROWERS MAKE DECISIONS ON
TRADEOFFS IN FUTURE DROUGHTS-
THE OTHER PROGRAM I WANTED TO
TOUCH ON THAT WE HAVE IN PLACE
RIGHT NOW IS OUR HEALTHY SOILS
PROGRAM. MANY PEOPLE AGO WHY
ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT HEALTHY
SOILS AND THIS IS ABOUT
DROUGHT. BUT THAT WHOLE ISSUE
OF WATER HOLDING CAPACITY IN
OUR SOILS UNDERSTANDING HOW
IMPROVING AND INCREASING SOIL
ORGANIC MATTER. WILL ACTUALLY
LEAD TO WATER HOLDING CAPACITY
IN THE SOILS WE FIGURE THAT.
FOR EACH 1% INCREASE IN SOIL
ORGANIC MATTER. WE ARE MAKING
AVAILABLE TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
GALLONS OF SOIL WATER THAT'S
THEREFORE USE LANCE OVER TIME
THIS WILL DRAMATICALLY INCREASE
OUR OUR RESILIENCY TO DROUGHT.
IT'S NOT OVERNIGHT BUT IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE STARTED BACK
IN THAT SHORT LIFETIME OF THIS
PROGRAM WE'VE INVESTED FORTY
ONE MILLION- DOLLARS OVER. SIX
HUNDRED AND FIFTY PROJECTS- FOR
REDUCTION IN GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS OF A HUNDRED AND TEN
THOUSAND METRIC TONS. VERY I
THINK VERY TELLING THAT WHEN E
THINK ABOUT THE WAYS THAT WE'RE
MAKING THESE INVESTMENTS WERE
REALLY LOOKING FOR MULTI
BENEFITS- AND SO WE'RE VERY
PLEASED THAT WE HAVE AN
ADDITIONAL FIFTY. MILLION
DOLLARS THAT'S BEEN INCLUDED IN
THE BUDGET- I WAS ASKED ALSO
TOUCH ON USDA PROGRAMS USDA HAS
A DIFFERENT METHOD FOR WORKING
ON WEDNESDAY DECLARED DISASTER
IT'S DRIVEN PRIMARILY BY THE
DROUGHT MONITOR. THAT SHOWS
GRASSLAND CONDITIONS. AND
WHAT'S HAPPENING AND RANGELAND
SO AS OF MARCH OF YEAR SEVENTY
BILLS MADE ANOTHER OF THIS
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM MORE READILY
AVAILABLE TO FARMERS AND
RANCHERS- SOME OF THOSE WORK
VERY WELL CALIFORNIA- NOT ALL
OF THEM DO AND SECRETARY BILL
SECOND SELF. HAS MADE A NOTE
THAT OUR EXISTING DISASTER
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS DO NOT WORK
WELL FOR DROUGHT AND THEY
ESPECIALLY DO NOT ACCOMMODATE
THE UNIQUENESS OF WESTERN
IRRIGATED AGRICULTURE AND
THAT'S ONE THING THAT I THINK
WE ALL WANT TO WORK ON
TOGETHER. YES WITH THE SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS HAS BEEN
INCLUDED BY CONGRESS AND
THEY'RE ADEQUATE CREATIONS.
BUDGETS IS THAT WERE VERY
ENGAGED AND EXPANDED THOSE
DISASTER PROGRAMS TO INCLUDE
DROUGHT AND WE WANT TO WORK
WITH RATIONAL DELEGATION TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY WILL
ACCOMMODATE. CALIFORNIA DROUGHT
THE OTHER THINGS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE THANK WOULD MAKE
THESE EASILY AVAILABLE ON OUR
WEBSITE. ARE ESPECIALLY HELPFUL
FOR THE RANGELAND AND JERRY
COMMUNITY FOR ASSISTANCE ON
FORAGE. HEY IS A VERY SHORT
SUPPLY THIS YEAR AND IT'S VERY
EXPENSIVE WHEN YOU CAN FIND
THAT AS WELL AS SHORT TERM
WATER HAULING. TO LIVE STOCK.
AVAILABLE EARLIER THIS U. S.
ALSO FORTY TWO. MILLION DOLLARS
BEING MADE AVAILABLE TO FOR
WESTERN STATES FOR A PILOT
PROGRAM ABOUT FORTY ONE POINT
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
CALIFORNIA WILL RECEIVE ALMOST
TWENTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS OF
THAT PROGRAM THROUGH THE
NATURAL RESOURCE CONSERVATION
SERVICE IT'S REALLY TAKING ALL
OF OUR CONSERVATION PROGRAMS
AND HOW DO WE MAXIMIZE THE USE
OF THOSE PROBLEMS SO YOU'D SEE-
OVER SEVEN HUNDRED APPLICATIONS
WERE RECEIVED IN A VERY SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME. DOZEN ELSE NOT
SHOULD BE COMING OUT IN
SEPTEMBER SO THAT'LL BE AN
ADDITIONAL TWENTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS A WEEK AND ON TOP OF
THAT USDA HAS MEGA BLOCK GRANTS
AVAILABLE TO THE KLAMATH
DROUGHT RELIEF AUTHORITY FOR
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
KLAMATH BASIN WHICH HAS BEEN
VERY VERY HARD YEAH THOSE WILL
BE PAYMENTS TO GROWERS TO
REDUCE THEIR WATER DEMAND AS A
WHITE AS A WAY TO TRY TO.
IMPROVE THE WATER AVAILABILITY
FOR THE SALMON AND SOME OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES THEY ARE
UP WITH THAT I ALSO WANT TO
POINT OUT I HOPE WE CAN WORK
TOGETHER ON FARM BILL PROGRAMS
GOING FORWARD IT'S NEVER TOO
EARLY TO TALK ABOUT THOSE
PROGRAMS AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU AS WE WORK OUR
WAY THROUGH- THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
ON DROUGHT AND WATER
RESILIENCY- THERE ARE SOME VERY
IMPORTANT PROGRAMS THAT WOULD
ALLOW AND HEALTH AND GROUND
WATER RECHARGE PROGRAMS. VERY
CRITICAL GOING FORWARD A LAND
REPURPOSE SAYING A MULTI DENNIS
ATLANTIC PURPOSING PROGRAM A
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
THEY CAN MAKE A BIG DIFFERENCE
MEDIA WAY ON DROUGHT IN THE
NEXT YEAR AS WELL AS LONG TERM
SUSTAINABILITY OF OUR
AGRICULTURAL LANDS IN THE BACK
END LOOK FORWARD TO CHRISTIANS
YEAH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SECRETARY KAREN ROSS WILL-
PROCEED WITH THE NEXT- FILE
SPEAKER THIS THAT CHAIRED WHAT
S. COMMAND STAY WATER RESOURCE
BOARD THANK YOU SIR AND YOU
JERRY AS WELL FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND BRING US
TOGETHER TODAY THE TALK ABOUT
SOMETHING THAT IS DEFINITELY
UNPRECEDENTED WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT THE SCALE OF DROUGHT YOU
HEARD PROFESSOR LINE GO OVER
THE DOCTOR OLOGY AND IT IS-
CURRENTLY SPEND- I TALK TOO
MUCH AND I WILL JUST SAY THAT I
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
INCREDIBLE WORK THAT ARE
COUNTIES AND LOCAL COMMUNITIES
HAVE BEEN DOING TO RESPOND TO
DROUGHT CONDITIONS IN THEIR
LOCAL. COMMUNITIES BUT ALSO
HAVING TO RESPOND TO OTHER
EMERGENCIES LIKE KOBE AND
CERTAINLY THE WILDFIRES THAT WE
ARE ALL ALSO YOU'LL BE HAPPY TO
RESPOND TO AT THE STATE I WANT
TO THANK THE LEADERSHIP AS WELL
HERE OF. SECRETARY ROSS AND THE
REST OF IT THE ADMINISTRATION
THIS HAS BEEN A WHOLE OF
GOVERNMENT APPROACH REALLY WHEN
IT COMES TO THE COMPLEX WAYS IN
WHICH DROUGHT IMPACTS ALL OF
OUR UNITY. AND AS WE RELATE
LOOK FOR THE FUTURE HERE AND
THINKING OF WHAT WE ALL NEED TO
BE DOING AS WE CONTINUE TO FIND
DRY CONDITIONS DROUGHT
CONDITIONS AND PREPARE FOR A
DRY WINTER AND HOPE THAT WE
DON'T HAVE ONE BUT WE HAVE TO
PREPARE NOW FOR CONTINUED DRY
CONDITIONS WE NEED COMMUNITIES
THAT CONTINUE TO ASSESS THEIR-
THEIR- THEIR SITUATIONS. AND
IMPORTANTLY WORK WITH THE STATE
AND THEY'RE COUNTY EMERGENCY
OFFICES THE BEST EVALUATE HOW
WE'RE ALL CONTINUE TO RESPOND
TO WHAT I KNOW IS A VERY
CHALLENGING SET OF. CONDITIONS
FOR A LOT OF US OUT THERE OVER
THE LAST MY THE BOY AND HAVE TO
TAKE EMERGENCY ACTION FOR ACT
AND DEVELOP EMERGENCY
CURTAILMENT REGULATIONS FOR
WATER RIGHT HOLDERS. IN KEY
WATERSHEDS AS YOU HEARD FROM
PROFESSOR LEARNED. THAT THERE
RUSSIAN RIVER WATERSHED WAS ONE
OF THE MORE. EARLIER WATERSHED
THAT WE UNDERSTOOD WORDS IN IN
NEED AND THE TROUBLE AND IN
FACT. LAST YEAR WE WORKED WITH
COMMUNITY TO ISSUE TEMPORARY
URGENCY CHANGE PETITIONS OUT
THERE KNOWING THAT THE WATER
BOARD. WHICH ARE RELAXATION OF
ENVIRONMENTAL STANDARDS TO HELP
RESPOND TO WHAT WERE ALREADY
DRY CONDITIONS LAST YEAR. AND
SO WE'VE HAD TO RESPOND HERE A
QUICK FASHION TO WORSENING
DROUGHT CONDITIONS IN THE
SPRING. WE FOUND AS AS
PROFESSOR LINE COVERED AT
NEARLY EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND
ACRE FEET. ARE NOT
MATERIALIZING WITHIN THE MAJOR
RESERVOIRS OF OUR STATE WATER
PROJECT AND CENTRAL VALLEY
PROJECT. THAT QUICK THE
DEEPENING OF DROUGHT IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE NEVER
SEEN AND IS REALLY
CHARACTERIZING. WHAT IS THE
SCOPE OF WORK THAT WE HAVE THE-
ABILITY TO SPREAD OVER A YEAR
YEAR AND A HALF IF YOU LOOK AT
THE CONDITIONS AS THEY SLOWLY
ENCROACHED ON THE LAST DROUGHT.
AND COMPRESS THEM HERE IN THE
SUMMER AND TAKE EXTRAORDINARY
ACTION- WHEN IT COMES TO. THE
CURTAILING CLOUT WATER RATES
AND I WATERSHED. THAT'S BECAUSE
AGAIN TRYING TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
PREPARING FOR A DRY WINTER WE
WANT TO KEEP AS MUCH WATER IN
OUR RESERVOIRS AS WE CAN NOW.
WE KNOW THAT CONDITIONS ARE AS
FAST AS THEY WILL BE AT LEAST
UNTIL WE START TO SEE ANY
RELIEF IF WE CAN DO. AND THE
NEW WATER HERE AND IT'S SO
IMPORTANT THAT WE ALL
COLLECTIVELY ARE CONTRIBUTING
TO OUR SUCCESS HERE. AND THAT'S
REALLY THE STORY OF CALIFORNIA.
IS A COLLECTIVE SUCCESS THAT
WE- ARE ALL ABLE TO DEMONSTRATE
WHEN IT COMES TO THAT VERY
ABILITY THAT PROFESSOR LINE
DISCUSSED. THAT THAT SWINGING
BETWEEN DROUGHT AND FLOOD AND
WE KNOW WITH CLIMATE CHANGE
THAT SWING BETWEEN THOSE TWO.
THOSE TWO STATES ARE ONLY GOING
TO GROW MORE INTENSE WE'LL HAVE
DRIER DROUGHTS. WE HAVE A WATER
SYSTEM. TRULY THAT WAS BUILT TO
THE TWENTIETH CENTURY AND WE
ARE NOW IN THE TWENTY FOUR
CENTURY WITH TWENTY FOUR
CENTURY AND TWENTY FIRST CHAO
SO IT'S ALL UPON US ABOUT HOW.
TO BEST. COLLECTIVELY WORK
THROUGH HOW WE WILL VIEW THESE
CHALLENGES AND REALLY SEE THEM
AS A GENERATIONAL OPPORTUNITY
TO REINVEST IN OUR WATER
SYSTEMS. TO RETHINK HOW WE MADE
MATT MIGHT MANAGE IN THE FACE
OF THE CLIMATE CRISIS. WITH
DEEPENING DROPS AND NO MORE
IMPORTANT DISCUSSION IS WITH
OUR AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITY
WHERE WE KNOW PARTICULARLY IN
RURAL COMMUNITIES. THE
INTERSECTION BETWEEN DRINKING
WATER ACCESS AND- AND
AGRICULTURE ARE SO IMPORTANT.
THAT WE NEED TO SEE OUR
COMMUNITIES HOLISTICALLY HERE.
AND IMPORTANTLY BRING BRING THE
BRING TO BEAR THE SORT OF
DECISION MAKING THAT WE ALL
COLLECTIVELY HAVE TO
DEMONSTRATE. IN THIS DROUGHT AS
THE PROFESSOR SAID WE DO NEED
TO GET MORE DATA BE MORE
GRANULAR AND BETTER MANAGE OUR
WATER RESOURCES PARTICULARLY
THE WATER RIGHT SPACE. INTO THE
NEXT INTO THE YEARS AHEAD WE'VE
GOT SOMEWHAT OF A LIGHT TOUCH
OUR WITH ADMINISTRATION OF
WATER RIGHTS IN THE STATE. AND
IF WE'RE GOING TO MANAGE
THROUGH YOUR DEEPER DROPS WE
HAVE TO GET BETTER AT TELLING
THE DROPS. TIGHTENING BY THE
ACTIONS OF THE MULTITUDE OF
WATER RIGHTS HOLDERS AND
WATERSHED. IN A WAY THAT MAKES
THEM ALL COLLECTIVELY
INDIVIDUALLY BETTER DECISION
MAKERS BUT IMPORTANTLY AS A
WATERSHED ALLOW US TO DO THAT.
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE BRING
ALONG COMMUNITIES AND- HELP.
DEVELOP THE COMMON DECISION
SUPPORT TOOLS NOT UNLIKE THE
ONES THAT SECRETARY. ELECTIVELY
FROM SOME GREATER RESOURCES
TEST SOME OF THESE CHALLENGES.
I'LL JUST SAY THAT I'M PROUD
THAT THE STATE WATER BOARD HAS
BEEN ABLE TO INVEST IN THE
LAST. FIVE OR FIVE YEARS SINCE
TWENTY SIXTEEN WHAT STRUCK. SIX
POINT THREE BILLION DOLLARS IN
THE STATE. THAT'S AND DRINKING
WATER INFRASTRUCTUREWASTEWATER
STORMWATER CAPTURE BROWN WATER
CLEAN UP IMPORTANTLY WATER
RECYCLING. WE HAVE TO BE MAKING
THESE INVESTMENTS INTO OUR AND
OUR COMMUNITIES AND THAT'S JUST
A SMALL DROP COMPARED TO ALL
THE LOCAL INVESTMENT THAT GOES
ON. TO CONTINUE TO MAINTAIN OUR
OUR OUR WATER SYSTEMS. BUT IN
THE FACE OF CLIMATE CHANGE AND
THE FACE OF THE AMOUNT OF
ADJUSTMENT WE NEED TO DO TO
MAKE TO OUR MANAGEMENT. WE'RE
GONNA NEED TO SEE GREATER
INVESTMENTS IN IS WHY I'M I'M
THANKFUL AND PROUD OF THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE LEGISLATURE
IN THE GOVERNOR FOR THE ONE
POINT THREE BILLION. THAT THE
BOARD IS PROVIDED FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS IN
DRINKING WATER AND WASTEWATER.
THOSE WATER RECYCLING PROJECTS
THEY MAY NOT SEEM TO BE. SUCH A
SOLUTION THAT AGRICULTURE CAN
REALLY TAP INTO BUT THEY ARE
AND THEY'RE EXAMPLES OF SUCCESS
AS WELL. DELPORT TO WATER
DISTRICT IN MODESTO BEING ABLE
TO REALLY MAXIMIZE AGAIN THAT
THE USE OF OUR OF WATER IN OUR
OUR COMMUNITY. AND SO WE'RE
WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO MAKING
THOSE INVESTMENTS HAVE THE DOWN
PAYMENT TO WHAT WE KNOW OUR
LARGER FEDERAL DISCUSSIONS AND
PREPARING OURSELVES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA BUT IMPORTANTLY IN
THE WEST AS WELL. FOR THE
CHALLENGES WILL BE FACING
BATCHES FROM DROUGHT BUT FROM
FLOOD AND IMPORTANTLY THAT
THERE ARE INVESTMENTS WE CAN BE
MAKING AND WILL CONTINUE TO DO
SO. IN ORDER TO IMPROVE ALL OF
OUR CONDITIONS HERE. SO THANK
YOU AND APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE IN THE
PORT FROM THE DISCUSSION THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN THE OTHER TWO
SPEAKERS WERE GOING TO- LOOK TO
THE- THE BODY HERE AND- SIX A
MONTH QUESTIONS IN THE COMMENTS
I. BELIEVE THERE IS A ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THAT WANTED TO. ASK SOME%
QUESTIONS. SO MEMBERS SALAS ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU MISS CURTIS
WANTED OUT REQUIRE BECAUSE YOU
KNOW IT'S BEEN ALLUDED TO THINK
BY A COUPLE OF THE PANELISTS
AND- MISTRUST ABOUT THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY IN AND- THE
SECRETARY WAS ON AS WELL BUT
JUST WANTED TO ASK. BUT YOU
KNOW WE'VE BEEN DOING A LOT OF
BUDGET ITEMS HERE ONE HEALTHY
INFRASTRUCTURES GONNA BE
HELPING WITH THAT YOU ALLUDED
TO THE ONE POINT THREE- AND
THEN I ALSO WANTED TO. JUST AN
UPDATE ON. THE DISCUSSIONS
AROUND SICK MY GIVEN THE
DROUGHT IS GETTING WORSE. IS
THERE ARE DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
DELAYING THAT IMPLEMENTATION OR
HOW IS. THE DEPARTMENT LOOKING
AT ADDRESSING. NOT ONLY THE
EXTREME DROUGHT BUT EVEN THE
SICK MY DEADLINES THAT LOOM
BEFORE US. ASSEMBLY MEMBER IS
THAT IS THAT DIRECTED TO CDFA
AS THE DEPARTMENTS. I'M HAPPY
TO THEIR STRUCTURE TO BOTH OF
YOU. THANK YOU OKAY ALL RIGHT-
I WAS THE FIRST AND SAY THAT
THE IMPLEMENTATION. AT THIS
STAGE IS WHAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES AND
UNFORTUNATELY WE DON'T HAVE A
REPRESENTATIVE HERE. THEY ARE
REVIEWING THOSE- I WOULD I
WOULD. CAUTION THAT. OF THE
INVESTMENTS THAT WE'RE MAKING
WITH THE FIVE POINT ONE BILLION
DOLLARS IS SIGNIFICANT
ESPECIALLY IF WE CAN LEVERAGE
THAT WIH FEDERAL DOLLARS. TO
THINK ABOUT THE INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT IS NECESSARY. TO HELP US
CAPTURE HE FLOWS AND DO SMART
WATER BANKING I KNOW YOU
REPRESENT PART OF KERN COUNTY
AND THEY CERTAINLY HAVE.
FIGURED THIS OUT BUT WATER
BANKING CAPTION. RECHARGE FLOWS
IS GOING TO BE AN IMPORTANT
PART BUT NOT THE ONLY PART OF
OUR FUTURE GOING FORWARD. WITH
THE REALITY OF SIGMA. IF WE IF
WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO HAVE A
SUSTAINABLE FUTURE FOR THE LONG
TERM. WE REALLY NEED TO
CONTINUE THE WORK THAT'S
HAPPENING ON THE SUSTAINABLE
GROUNDWATER MANAGEMENT ACT. I'M
NOT AWARE OF ANYONE WHO'S WHO'S.
PUSHING FOR DELAY AT THIS TIME
DEFINITELY ALSO I'LL SEE IF THE
INVESTMENT ARE ARE SIMPLY ARE
DEFINITELY A MULTITUDE BUT CAN
BE TWO FOLD THING IT'S ABOUT
THE DRINKING WATER SYSTEMS AND
THE SYSTEM THAT THAT CAN BAY
DRINKING WATER TO COMMUNITIES.
BUT ALSO. ON A LARGER SCALE HOW
WATER IS MANAGED AND IN
WATERSHEDS IN THERE THE
SECRETARY PROCESS POINT WE NEED
TO GET SMARTER AND BE ABLE TO
IMPROVE THE CALL QUALITY AND
CONDITION OF OUR GROUNDWATER
BASINS. BECAUSE THEY SHARE THAT
RESOURCE WITH DRINKING WATER
AND IS SO CRITICAL FOR
AGRICULTURE TO BE ABLE TO
DEPEND UPON IT DURING A
DROUGHT. IN THIS PAINFUL AND I
KNOW IT'S HARD IS BUSINESS
THINK MUCH CAN SEEM IN THESE IN
THESE SPACES HERE I THINK IT
JUST REALLY EMPHASIZES THE
IMPORTANCE OF THOSE DISCUSSIONS
TO REALLY. BEGIN TO UNDERSTAND
HOW WE'RE GOING TO MANAGE THIS
RESOURCE TO LOOK FOR THE LONG
TERM KNOWING THAT IT'S SO
IMPORTANT TO. AGRICULTURE AND
PEOPLE LIKE COMMUNITIES AND
IT'S AND IT'S UNDERSTANDING HOW
WATER UNDERGROUND AND THEN BE
ABLE TO MOVE IT WHEN IT'S FAIR
THREE TIMES OF. OF FLOODS AND
WHEN THERE'S ACCESS IT'S GONNA
BE REALLY IMPORTANT AND THERE'S
WATER RIGHTS COMPONENT THERE
IMPORTANTLY WHERE WE NEED TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND AND THE
MOVEMENT OF THAT WATER WHO.
BEST HAS PRIORITY IN RIGHT AND
BEGIN TO REALLY WORK WITHIN THE
WATER RIGHTS SYSTEM TO ENSURE
THAT IF THEY'RE TO ADAPT TO
CLIMATE CHANGE TO BE HERE WITH
US AS A TOOL. AS OPPOSED TO
IMPEDIMENT WITCHING QUICKLY
BECOME IF WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
DATA TO BE MAKING DIFFICULT
DECISIONS. AROUND THOSE REAL
CRITICAL PROJECTS THANK YOU AND
IF I MAY JUST A FOLLOW UP
THROUGH THE CHAIR BY APPRECIATE
THAT I APPRECIATE YOU TALK
ABOUT WATER BANKING I KNOW.
EARLY ON WHEN I FIRST GOT
ELECTED WE TALKED ABOUT WATER
BREAKING. THROUGHOUT THE STATE
AND I WAS TOLD AT THE TIME I
THINK IT WAS- DEPARTMENT WATER
RESOURCES. WAS TAUGHT WAS
SAYING THAT. WE CAN CREATE
REGIONAL WATER BANKING AND
FIFTY OUT OF THE FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. TO ME IT SEEMS
LIKE- AS WE- YOU KNOW HAVE THIS
FIVE POINT ONE BILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT MAYBE THAT'S- THE
STRATEGY WE PURSUE IS WATER
BANKING AND EACH OF THE
DIFFERENT COUNTY SO THEN. WE
DON'T RUN INTO- SOME OF THE
OTHER OBSTACLES OF.
TEMPERATURES INFLOWS AND-
TURNING ON THE BANKS THAT THE
WATER BREAK AT. THE PUMPS OF
TURNING OFF THE PUMPS ARE NOT-
SO ACTUALLY LOOK FORWARD TO IT
IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU GUYS ARE
PROPONENTS OF. OF WATER BANKING
IT MAY BE THAT I'M HOPING
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT GETS
PURSUED AS WE- START DIVESTING
THIS AND THESE INVESTMENT
DOLLARS. AND THEN SECONDLY I
DIDN'T REALLY HEAR. AN ANSWER
ON THE SIGMA QUESTION SO JUST
THAT THERE'S DISCUSSIONS BUT-
REALLY NOTHING- HARD AND FAST
ABOUT WHETHER IT'S BEING GOING
TO BE DELAYED OR NOT SOCREDS.
THAT'S CORRECT I KNOW OF NO
DISCUSSION ABOUT DELAYING AND
AGAIN I I'VE I'VE READ ABOUT
SOME COMMUNITIES TALKING ABOUT
HOW DO WE REALLY LEAN AND HOW
DO WE ACCELERATE THE WORK GIVEN
HOW IMPORTANT IT IS IN THE-
CASE OF DROUGHT. SOME MEMBER.
SMITH SERVICE GOING TO WORK
TODAY WALKING HOW ARE YOU
TODAY. MY QUESTION IS DO IT
WITH IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN
WITH PROPOSITION ONE FUNDING
HOW MUCH MONEY HAS BEEN SPENT
IN WATER STORAGE FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. NOT COUNTING THE
ORVILLE. FROM MAINTENANCE
PROJECTS OR OF THE PROJECT BUT
HOW MUCH MONEY HAS BEEN SPENT
ON WATER STORAGE. I APOLOGIZE
I'M WITH THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD OUR OUR
CHUNK OF THE PROBLEM BOND
DOLLARS WASN'T I DIDN'T INCLUDE
THE STORAGE I DOLLARS I CAN'T
SAY WHEN IT COMES TO THE
DOLLARS THE BOARD HAS RECEIVED-
DURING A PROP ONE FOR WATER
RECYCLING. DRINKING WATER
WASTEWATER GROUNDWATER CLEANUP
STORMWATER CAPTURE THAT THOSE
DOLLARS ARE OUT I'M MAKING A
DIFFERENCE NOW AND IMPORTANTLY
HELPING US BUILD RESILIENCY I
KNOW THAT WE ARE ARE ARE
FURTHER ALONG ON. THE
DISCUSSION AROUND THOSE STORAGE
DOLLARS AND SECRETARY ROSS I
DON'T KNOW IF. YOU HAVE A BIT
CHECK OUT ON THAT I KNOW THAT-
IT IS AN IMPORTANT COMPONENT
AND IMPORTANTLY THOSE THOSE
PROJECTS THEMSELVES HAVE TO BE
READY AND FAR ENOUGH ALONG TO
REALLY BE ABLE TO RECEIVE THOSE
OTHERS NUMBER OF-
QUALIFICATIONS WITHIN THE
PROGRAM. AND I KNOW THAT THAT
THERE IS A CERTAIN ROUND IS
ALREADY BEEN COMMITTED TO YOU-
AND AT THIS POINT FOR THEIR
WORK AND I APOLOGIZE. IT'S NOT-
WITHIN THAT THE STATE WATER
BOARDS FOR YOU NECESSARILY OKAY
AND MAYBE A FOLLOW UP TO IS
WITH THE SITES RESERVOIR KNOW
WHAT'S BEEN GOING ON- FORTY
FIVE FIFTY YEARS. WILL WE EVER
SEE THAT STORAGE PROJECT THE-
DO IT FOR ATTENTION AND BE
BUILT. OKAY THAT THE STATE
BOARD IS HERE TO DO WITH PART
AND MAKING SURE AND WORKING
WITH- THE LOCAL PROJECT
PROPONENTS I KNOW THAT THERE'S
A WATER RIGHTS COMPONENT. TO
THOSE STORAGE PROJECTS AND OUR
STAFF ARE ARE WORKING WITH
EARLY WITH THE APPLICANTS AND
MAKING SURE THAT THE BOARD IS
IN A BOTTLE NECK AS- THOSE
PROJECTS CONTINUE THEIR THEIR
POINT OF- THE WASHINGTON THAT.
AND OUTDOOR KEEP PUSHING FOR
WATER STORAGE BUT IN THE BUDGET
I ASK FOR BILLION DOLLAR FOR
WATER STORAGE EARLIER THIS
YEAR. AND I GOT VOTED OUT SO
I'M HOPING MY COLLEAGUES TO
LOOK IN THE FUTURE I THINK
WATER STORAGE WILL BE THE KEY.
FOR ALL OF US DRINKING WATER
FARMERS AND STORAGE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
THE SUMMER- SUMMER WOULD. YES
THANK YOU AND I'D QUESTION FOR
THE CHAIR HERE WHO SEEMS TO BE
GETTING A LOT OF THESE
QUESTIONS BUT CREATE THAT- YOU
KNOW I HEAR A LOT FROM
CONSTITUENTS IN MY DISTRICT
ABOUT- CERTAINLY CHALLENGES
AROUND WATER RIGHTS IN
PARTICULAR- WIN THEY CAN DIVERT
WATER- AND SO MANY IN MANY
AREAS OF MY DISTRICT WATER
DIVERSION HAPPENS DURING THE
SUMMERTIME YET IT WOULD BE
REALLY MUCH MORE BENEFICIAL TO
DIVERT WATER IN THE WINTER TIME
TO. FOR OFF STREAM STORAGE-
OUTSIDE THE ASHRAM SORT YET THE
CHALLENGE WITH CHANGING THOSE
WATER RIGHTS AND THE LACK THAT
IS IT HAS REALLY. IS REALLY A
PROBLEM IS IT DO YOU SEE IN THE
FUTURE SIMPLEX INCREASE
FLEXIBILITY AROUND THAT SOURCE
STREAMLINING THE PROCESS EVEN
IN PARTS OF MY DISTRICT WE HAVE
YOU KNOW PEOPLE THAT HAVE THE
ABILITY TO CREATE PONDS FOR
STORAGE. THEY OFTEN RUN INTO
VERY AN EVEN ENFORCEMENT OF THE
RULES AROUND WHO WHERE YOU CAN
HOW YOU BUILD UPON IT VARIES
FROM COUNTY TO COUNTY AND IT
CAN BE REALLY FRUSTRATING SO
THERE HAVE BEEN BILLS IN THE
LEGISLATURE TO STREAMLINE THAT.
BUT IF YOU ASK FOLKS OUT IN
THE- LIVING IT IT DOESN'T FEEL
VERY STREAMLINED. YEAH I
APPRECIATE THAT I AS I SAID THE
WATER RIGHTS SYSTEM HAS TO BE
THERE TO BE ABLE TO. HELP US
ADAPT TO CLIMATE CHANGE AND
HAVE A THE ABILITY FOR WATER
RIGHTS HOLDERS TO DO THE
EXACTLY THE WORK THAT YOU'RE
SAYING I KNOW THAT. WHEN WE
LOOK AT OUR NORTH OUR WORK IN
THE NORTH COAST AND IN THE AREA
I KNOW INTEREST YOUR COUNTY
PARTICULARLY. WE ARE WE'RE
WE'RE ENCOURAGING THAT SORT OF
MOVEMENT FROM DIVERSION DURING
THOSE TIMES WHEN YOU KNOW
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH DURING THE
WATER DURING DURING WINTERTIME
SO. WE'RE WE'RE HERE REPUTED TO
MAKING SURE THAT WE DO. AND YOU
TO INVEST IN OUR WATER RIGHTS
ADMINISTRATION I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THOUGH TO HAVE A
DISCUSSION AROUND THE FACT THAT
NOTE NINETY FOURTEEN IN RECORD
RIGHT HOLDERS THE NECESSARY
PAYMENT TO THE ADMINISTRATION-OF WATER RIGHTS AND MAYBE
THERE'S WAYS THAT WE CAN ALL.
COLLECTIVELY YOUR PICK UP SOME
LOW HANGING FRUIT TO THINK
ABOUT HOW WE BETTER RESOURCE
THE ADMINISTRATION OF IT I KNOW
THAT WE NOW HAVE AN OFFICE OF
ADMINISTRATING. ADMINISTRATIVE
HEARINGS OFFICE AND WANT TO
THANK THE LEGISLATURE FOR THAT
WE'VE BEGUN TO START TO. HAVE
MORE MOVEMENT IF YOU WILL
WITHIN THE WATER RATES DECISION
MAKING SPACE SO THAT ALL THESE
DECISIONS DON'T HAVE TO JUST
COME TO THE BOARD WE HAVE A
DEDICATED OFFICE THEY CAN BEGIN
TO WORK THROUGH. THE WATER
ITCHEN MINISTRATION AND LATE
THROUGH. A SOME DECISIONS AND I
THINK THAT USING THOSE
RESOURCES ARE IMPORTANT BUT
IMPORTANTLY ALSO LOOKING UP
WATER RATES. AT LARGE A BET AND
THINKING HOW BEST TO RESOURCE
IT HOW BEST WE MAKE SURE IT
WORKS FOR OUR COMMUNITIES.
YOU'RE GOING INTO THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY BECAUSE IT IS SO
IMPORTANT IT IS. ALLOWING A
MOCKING THAT DECISION MAKING
AND ON THE WATERSHED SCALE IN
WAYS THAT. YOU CAN HELP US
BETTER MANAGE THROUGH THE
CHALLENGES SO THANK YOU SO THE
MEMBERSHIP THAT. THANK YOU
RIGHT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS-
MISTER MESSAGING THANK YOU VERY
MUCH A- CHAIR GARCIA AND THE
CHAIR RIVAS FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
IN BRINGING UP THIS URGENT
ISSUE- I APOLOGIZE SO I MISSED
SOME PART PORTIONS OF THE
HEARING ALTHOUGH I WAS TRYING
TO WATCH A FIRM- THE TV
MONITOR- MISTER CHAIR RIVAS.
TALKED ABOUT HOW YOU KNOW THE.
GROWING REALIZATION OF THE
CLIMATE CRISIS BEING HERE AND
NOW. BEING MANIFESTED IN THE
DROUGHT REALITIES THAT WE'RE
SEEING THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. YOU KNOW IT'S
REALLY BRING IT HOME THE
URGENCY OF THE ISSUES THAT ARE
BEING ADDRESSED TODAY I DO WANT
TO GO INTO PERHAPS RAISE A
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE FROM WHAT
I'VE BEEN HEARING FROM SOME OF
MY COLLEAGUES YOU KNOW AS A
REPRESENTATIVE OF I MERRILY A
SUBURBAN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DISTRICT- I DON'T HAVE ANY
AGRICULTURE MY DISTRICT. BUT
THE YOU KNOW I DO KNOW THAT YOU
KNOW FOR EXAMPLE WHEN IT TOOK A
RECENT ROAD TRIP WITH MY FAMILY
FROM. LOS ANGELES- ALL THE WAY
THROUGH- THAT THE- CENTRAL
VALLEY A TO SACRAMENTO AND THEN
UP TO THE NORTHERN BORDER OF
THE STATE. THAT I FELT LIKE I
GOT A- A SPECTRUM OF EVIDENCE
OF THE CLIMATE CRISIS
MANIFESTING ITSELF IN IN TERMS
OF THE DROUGHT CONDITIONS YOU
KNOW IT EVERYTHING FROM SEEING
THE RESERVOIRS- AT- YOU KNOW
ALARMINGLY LOW LEVELS TO-
SEEING TO- YOU KNOW HOW MANY OF
THE SIGNS ALONG THE I. FIVE-
SIGNS CALLING ON GOVERNOR
NEWSOM TO BUILD MORE WATER
STORAGE- AND- BUT WHAT REALLY
STRUCK ME THE MOST WAS- SEEING
ALL THE ALMOND ORCHARDS AND THE
YOU KNOW. I KNOW THIS IS NOT
GONNA BE A VERY POPULAR ABOUT
PERSPECTIVE BUT I JUST READ A
RECENT ARTICLE. IN THE ATLANTIC
MAGAZINE ABOUT HOW YOU KNOW
WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE JUST NOT
PRACTICING SUSTAINABLE
AGRICULTURE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND AND IT IT IT
JUST SEEMS LIKE YOU KNOW WERE
THE AQUIFER'S ARE BEING DRAINED
THE LAND IS SINKING AND YOU
KNOW DESPITE WHAT WE OFTEN HEAR
FROM THE AGRICULTURE INDUSTRY
THAT THAT THEY CARE MORE. ABOUT
BEING GOOD STEWARDS OF THE LAND
I DON'T SEE THAT HAPPENING AND
I SEE ALL THE TO THE TOUGH TALK
ALL THE CALLS ABOUT INCREASED
WATER STORAGE MERELY GOING
TOWARD SUBSIDIZING WHAT SEEMS
TO BE AN UNSUSTAINABLE
AGRICULTURE INDUSTRY AND SO I
I'M SORRY I GOT A CALL OUT THE
ALMOND INDUSTRY- YOU KNOW THAT
THAT'S JUST ONE EXAMPLE THAT
THAT HAS BEEN IN THE- AT LEAST
IN THIS ARTICLE THAT WAS
DISCUSSED BUT I. I WANTED TO
ASK A- AND ANY OF THE SPEAKERS
A MINUTE IT I KNOW THAT YOU
KNOW THEY'RE- ONE OF THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKERS ASKED ABOUT.
POSTPONING THE DEADLINE FOR
SIGMA MY CONCERN IS THAT WE'RE
PUTTING IT OFF TOO FAR AND
THAT- YOU KNOW WE ARE NOT DOING
ENOUGH QUICKLY ENOUGH IN ORDER
TO. PROTECT THE LAND THAT THAT
HAS BEEN- SO FERTILE FOR SO
MANY GENERATIONS FOR
GENERATIONS INSTEAD OF
CALIFORNIANS- IS THERE ANY
EFFORT. TO FOCUS ON THE
UNSUSTAINABLE AGRICULTURAL
PRACTICES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO THAT WE CAN
ADDRESS AND REALLY YOU KNOW
FACE HEAD ON THE REALITIES IN
OVER THE THAT OF CLIMATE CHANGE
THE REALITIES OF THE DROUGHT
CONDITION THAT'S ONLY GOING TO
GET WORSE- RATHER THAN JUST
CONTINUE TO KICK THE- CAN DOWN
THE ROAD. SOMEONE THEN I'M
GOING TO MAKE AN ASSUMPTION
THAT MAY BE DIRECTED TOWARDS
THE DEPARTMENT OF AGRICULTURE.
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
VIEWPOINT- IT IS CLEARLY
SOMETHING THAT- AS WATER
RELIABILITY AND AFFORDABILITY
DICTATE MORE AND MORE THE KINDS
OF CROPS WOULD GROW IN THE
STATE. AT THAT ALREADY HAS OF
THE LAST THREE DECADES. WE HAVE
SEEN THE MOVEMENTS. OF BASED ON
AVAILABILITY OF WATER SUITABLE
SOILS AVAILABILITY OF LABOR.
AND RETURNS ON INVESTMENT FOR
THOSE FAMILY FARMERS MOVE TO
HIGHER AND HIGHER VALUE
SPECIALTY CROPS LIKE ALMONDS.
THERE'S ALSO A MOVE TO GO TO A
PROP LIKE ALMONDS BECAUSE WE'RE
ONE OF ONLY FIVE MEDITERRANEAN
CLIMATES. AND REPRODUCE OVER
80% OF THAT THE GLOBAL SUPPLY
OF COMMONS. AND AS WE HAVE
WATCHED ALMONDS MOVE NOT JUST
FROM BEING A LUXURY. SNAP CROP
TO BEING A VERY STRONG BASIS OF
A PLANT BASED DIET WITH ALL THE
WAYS THAT ALMONDS ARE NOW USED
AS WELL AS OTHER TREE NUTS AND
OTHERS. THERE HAS BEEN A NEW
FOR ECONOMIC REASONS AS WELL AS
THE ALMOND BOARD OF CALIFORNIA
HAS A VERY ROBUST SUSTAINABLE
AGRICULTURE PROGRAM. THEY HAS
THAT GOAL BY TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE. TO REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF
WATER USED TO PRODUCE A POUND
OF ALMONDS BY TWENTY PERCENT.
THEY SET A SUSTAINABILITY GO BY
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. CHIU
IMPROVE THE USE OF
ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY PEST
MANAGEMENT TOOLS BY TWENTY FIVE
PERCENT. THEY HAVE SET A GOAL
TO REDUCE WASTE FROM THE
ORCHARDS. ZERO ZERO SO THEY ARE
MAKING VERITIES SALE. ON
SUSTAINABILITY BOTH IN THAT AND
IN THAT REGARD AS HAS OUR DAIRY
INDUSTRY JERRY HAS REDUCED ITS-
USE OF WATER TO PRODUCE A.
GALLON OF MILK BY 88% OVER THE
LAST FEW CLASS PROCESSING OF
IMPROVED THEIR WATER EFFICIENCY
SO THAT THEY USE PERCENT LESS
Y. BUT THEY AND THEIR BY
PERCENT THOSE ARE THE TYPES OF
RATIOS THAT ALLOW FOR LONG TERM
SUSTAINABILITY. OF CROPS THAT
CAN'T BE GRANTED THAT MANY
OTHER PLACES. I'M MORE THAN
HAPPY TO MEET WITH YOU AT ANY
TIME TO TALK MORE ABOUT OUR
SUSTAINABLE ACT PROGRAMS AND
OUR CLIMATE SMART ACT PROGRAMS
BUT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
POINT OUT. THE WAY THAT WE GROW
THESE ARE MORE EFFICIENT THAN
ANY OTHER ACTION SYSTEM THAT I
NOW UP ON A GLOBAL BASIS THANKS
FOR. THANK YOU SECRETARY WE
HAVE ANOTHER QUESTION. SCHOLAR
THANK THANK YOU MISTER AND I
APPRECIATE THAT ANSWER AND THE
QUESTION OF WHICH STATE ARE
CALLING GIVE FOR. YOUR CONCERN
BUT HONESTLY WE TO HEAR ABOUT
HOW MUCH THE MEAT AND DAIRY
INDUSTRY USES. ARE NOT JUST IN
TERMS OF WATER BUT IN TERMS
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS. AND
SO- I DO- AND HAD WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK ON. LEGISLATION TO
HELP- YOU KNOW THE- A-
TRANSITION FOR THOSE THAT ARE
INTERESTED- TO VOTE MORE
TOWARDS PLANT BASED AND
SUSTAINABLE. PLANT BASED PLANT
BASED MEANS A LOT OF DIFFERENT
THINGS. IN TERMS OF OUR- PLANTS
AND VEGETABLES AND FRUITS THAT.
WE GROW- WHICH WE'VE GROW
BETTER THAN ANYWHERE ELSE IN
THE WORLD WHICH IS A GREAT
THING AND I'M REALLY HAPPY TO
HEAR ABOUT. OTHER CONTINUED
EFFORTS BY OUR AGRICULTURE
INDUSTRY ACROSS THE BOARD- TO
REDUCE. WATER CONSUMPTION. AND
YOUR ANY THOUGHTS OR OR AT
LEAST- I'LL JUST PUT IT OUT
THERE IN TERMS OF- THAT
CONTINUED MOVE TOWARDS MORE
SUSTAINABLE. TYPES OF CROPS
WHICH I THINK IS SOMETHING THAT
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO DO NOT JUST
HERE BUT GLOBALLY AND IS BEEN
RECOGNIZED. ON A GLOBAL LEVEL
IN TERMS OF HOW OUR CURRENT.
FOOD SYSTEM IS ABSOLUTELY
UNSUSTAINABLE- AND THAT HAS
MORE TO DO WITH- WITH- WITH A-
LARGE LIVESTOCK WOULD HAVE YOU
THAN ANYTHING ELSE NOT JUST
HERE BUT GLOBALLY BUT OF COURSE
WE CAN. FOCUS ON WHAT WE NEED
TO DO HERE THANK GOODNESS
BECAUSE AWARD TO IF WE HAVE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM- THE COLLEAGUES HERE WE'RE
GONNA JUMP INTO THE- SECOND
PANEL BEFORE WE DO THAT. THANK
ALL THREE OF OUR OUR
PRESENTERS. WE HAVE OKAY WE
HAVE ONE MICROPHONE GOING UP.
SOME MEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY MUCH
EITHER OF YOU HAVE MANY WAY I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CAN'T A I
REALLY APPRECIATE- KERN WHEN
YOU'VE SHARED WITH EVERYONE I
WANT TO BE THE FIRST TO SAY
I'LL TAKE YOU ON A TOUR AND I
THINK YOU'RE GOING TO BE
SHOCKED THIS THE THINGS THAT
FARMERS ARE DOING. YOU KNOW I'M
GONNA BE THE FIRST TO MID IS A
FARMER I'M A TIGHT WAD AND I
LOOK FOR EVERY WAY TO SAVE
MONEY I LOOK EVERYWHERE TO SAVE
WATER I LOOK FOR THE GOOD OF
THE CROPS THAT OBVIOUSLY ARE OF
HIGHER VALUE BECAUSE I HAVE TO
MAKE A LIVING ON A SMALL EIGHTY
ACRE RANCH WITH MY BROTHERS SO
I THINK THAT- I FEEL A LITTLE
BIT TAKEN BACK HERE ABOUT- A
LITTLE BIT NOT EVEN MAYBE I
HAVEN'T REACHED OUT TO ENOUGH
OF YOU TO TAKE YOU ON A TOUR TO
SEE WHAT FARMERS ARE DOING.
RIGHT NOW IN THE MIDDLE OF
TAUGHT TOMATO HARVEST AND WHAT
THEY'RE DOING IS HELP WITH THE
HOURS OF THAT THAT THEY WORK
OUT THEIR HOW THEY HAVE HOW
THEY WATER WHY BROADBAND IS SO
IMPORTANT SO THEY CAN MAKE SURE
THAT THEY DON'T USE TOO MUCH
WATER THE READING I CALCULATE
THAT OUT I MEAN THERE'S SO MANY
THINGS I THINK THAT
UNFORTUNATELY- NOT ALL OF YOU
UNDERSTAND. AND I AM MORE THAN
WILLING TO TAKE YOU TO ANY
TOWARD THE YOU'D LIKE ONLY
THIRTY MINUTES AWAY AND YOU CAN
SEE SOME OF THE INCREDIBLE
THINGS ARE DOING UC DAVIS IS
ONE OF THE TOP NOTCH GO
UNIVERSITY AND THEY'RE DOING-
INCREDIBLE THINGS OF MATH THING
HOUSE DERRY AND I JUST THINK
THAT WE'RE NOT TAPPING INTO
THEM ENOUGH SO THAT YOU
UNDERSTAND THAT THAT WE ARE
GOING TO BE SUSTAINABLE AND I
AS A FARMER- I WILL TELL YOU
THAT EVERY FARMER I KNOW. IS.
ALWAYS TRYING TO FIND A BETTER
WAY TO DO BUSINESS THANK YOU
SOME AND THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS AND-
AGAIN FOR- THREE PANELISTS. FOR
BEING WITH US TODAY AND
PROVIDING THE INSIGHT. MY
COLLEAGUES ARE CHAIRMAN RIVAS
WILL. PRESENT THE- NEXT
PANELIST AND THAT CLOSURES SOME
OF IT ON THE SECOND PANEL- WILL
BE TALKING ABOUT US DROUGHT
IMPACTS ON FARMERS AND RANCHERS
THE FIRST ON THE PANEL IS- MISS
JENNIFER. BERETTA OF- THE BREAD
UP FAMILY DAIRY FROM SANTA ROSA
SO MISBRANDED HERE WITH US
IT'S- IT'S ALL YOURS THANK YOU
KNOW SOMEONE REQUESTS- MY NAME
IS JENNIFER BERETTA I'M A
FOURTH GENERATION DAIRY FARMER
IN THE NORTH COAST IN SANTA
ROSA- I ALSO IN A SIX
GENERATION FARMER IN MARIN
COUNTY SO BOTH OF OUR FARMS.
ARE EXPERIENCING THE DROUGHT IN
DIFFERENT WAYS SO I'M GONNA
TALK ON THAT TODAY I'M IN
CENTER THAT WE'VE BEEN HEARING
SINCE NINETEEN FORTY EIGHT. AND
WE WERE ORGANIC IN TWO THOUSAND
AND SIX- KNOWING THAT WE CAN NO
LONGER COMPETE- IN THE BIGGER
MARKET AND IN THE NORTH COAST
WE ARE MORE- IS THAT MORE NICHE
AND WE ARE PASSED YOUR BE
SCARY. WE CURRENTLY SELL REMOTE
TO CLOVER SO NO MATTER- AS WELL
AS MY MOM'S JERRY IN MARIN
COUNTY. WHICH IS ABOUT THREE
THOUSAND ACRES OF DRYLAND
FARMING AND NOT THEY DEPEND ON
RAIN WATER TO CAPTURE INTO
THEIR DAMS TWO WATER TOWERS AND
WASH THE BAR DOWN- WE'VE BEEN
THROUGH DROUGHT FOR THE LAST
YOU KNOW TWELVE. OF SEVENTY
YEARS MY UNCLE SAID THAT- IN
SEVENTY SEVEN I WAS THE FIRST
TIME THEY HAD A WHOLE WATER AND
HE HASN'T HAD A WHOLE WATER
SINCE AN HOUR IN TWO THOUSAND
AND ONE- WE SAW IN DECEMBER
THAT THERE WAS NOT GOING TO BE
ANY RUN OFF THIS YEAR AND WE
DECIDED TO START SELLING SOME
COWS. KNOWING THATFEED COSTS
WERE GOING TO BE HIGHER- ARE
CASHIER WAS NOT GOING TO BE
WHAT IT SHOULD BE- AND WE USE
IT HERE IN SANTA ROSA AND THE
CITY OF SANTA ROSA RECLAIMED
WASTEWATER- AND THAT'S BEEN A
GREAT PARTNERSHIP FOR THIRTY
YEARS AND I WE GOT OUR INCHES
CUT IN HALF- SAID KNOWING THAT
ALL THESE THINGS ARE GOING TO
BE COMING DOWN THE PIPELINE WE
HAD TO MAKE SOME VERY- HARD
CALLS. I'M AS WELL AS BE VERY
DILIGENT AROUND US- WE ARE
SURROUNDED BY CITY SANTA ROSA
PROPERTY THAT NORMALLY IF
YOU'RE GETTING IT AND- LESS
THAN TWO WEEKS AGO WE HAD A
FIRE ACROSS THE STREET. THAT
ALMOST TOOK OUT OUR DAIRY AND
HAVE THOSE LANDS BEEN YOUR
GATED- I FEEL LIKE THAT WOULD
HAVE SLOWED THE PROGRESS- BUT-
WITHOUT WATER OBVIOUSLY RUNNING
OFF TO THE PINES- WE DO NOT
HAVE THAT WATER AVAILABLE FOR
ALL THAT ACREAGE- WE. RELY ON
GROWING MOST OF HER FEET. WE
THE GIRL ABOUT HOW ACRES SILENT
AND THEN TRY TO GO A SET AND
THIRD HAY THIS YEAR WE'RE
ACTUALLY GOING TO BE. TRUCKING
IN MORE HEY WE'VE HAD TO FEED
OUR ANIMALS SOONER THAN NORMAL-
BECAUSE OUR PASTURE LAND IS NOT
WHAT IT SHOULD BE- FEED COSTS
ARE. FLYING THROUGH THE ROOF-
AND SO IT'S GOING TO BE HARDER
FOR US TO. CONTINUE TO JERRY
AND I FEEL LIKE THE IMPACTS ON
THE DAIRY INDUSTRY IN THE NORTH
COAST. HAVE YET TO BE SEEN IF
WE DON'T GET RAIN IN THE WINTER
TIME YOU WILL PROBABLY SEE
MULTIPLE JERRY SPOT OF
BUSINESS- BECAUSE THERE'S JUST
PHYSICALLY NO WATER TO WATER
THEIR ANIMALS. AND NO FEE
DEFEAT THEM- ALSO ON THE U.
TRUCKING AND FEED YOU KNOW WE
IN THE DAIRY INDUSTRY HAVE TRY
TO CUT EMISSIONS BY METHANE AND
WE DO ALL THAT WE CAN BUT AS
WE'RE TRACKING AND MORE FEET
FROM OTHER STATES. ARE DOING IS
INCREASING OUR MISSION BUT
BRAND THAT'S NOT WHAT WE HAVE
THE DAIRY INDUSTRY HAS TRIED TO
DO- SO. WE ALSO DID EIGHT EYES
CDFA WE ARE ONE OF THE CDFA
IMPRINT THIS YEAR. AND WE'VE
SEEN THE BENEFITS AND NOT AS
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO REUSE A
SEPARATED WATER OFF OF ARE
SEPARATED IN YOUR BACK ONTO OUR
FIELDS. SO THAT'S BEEN A GREAT
PARTNERSHIP WE ALSO DID THE
HEALTHY SOILS PROGRAM AND I
WOULD LIKE TO KIND OF TOUCH ON
WHAT SECRETARY ROSS TALKED
ABOUT WITH ALL THE PROGRAMS AND
FUNDING. I WOULD HAVE TO SAY
THAT AS WE PUSH THESE PROGRAMS-
TO HOPEFULLY. HOLD OUR CDFA
ACCOUNTABLE AND HOLD USD
ACCOUNTABLE BECAUSE THE HEALTHY
SOILS PROGRAM. WAS ONE OF THE
HARDEST PROGRAMS I'VE EVER
DEALT WITH NOT ONLY TO GET OUR
FUNDS. BUT WHEN IT CAME TO
DURING KOBE TIME JUST GETTING A
RESPONSE BACK. FROM WHO I WAS
WORKING WITH AND USDA WE'VE HAD
FUN SITTING OUT FOR DROUGHT-
FOR THE LAST FIVE MONTHS WE
HAVE NOT GOT ANY OF OUR FUNDS
SO THESE PROGRAMS ARE GREAT.
BUT I REALLY STRIVED ACT- THE
STATE AND CDFA PUSH- THAT
THEY'RE EASIER FOR FARMERS. AND
I'M NOT THERE YOU KNOW EASIER
FOR US TO GET OUR FUNDS- I
CALLED ACTION. FOR THE
COMMUNITY TO THINK ABOUT HOW WE
CAN TAKE MOST OF THIS
REGIONALLY. I TALK ABOUT-
RECLAIM. WASTEWATER SYSTEM WE
USE FOR THIRTY YEARS HOW CAN WE
BY HOW CAN WE YOU DON'T OUR FOR
OUR FARMLAND GIVEN THAT WAS CUT
IN HALF BUT- URBAN AND THE
GEYSERS WERE HALF OF THAT WATER
GOES FOR ELECTRICITY WAS NOT
CUT. BUT WHAT WE DO ON OUR
FARMERS WE RECHARGE THE GROUND
BY UTILIZING THAT WATER
IRRIGATION. AND THAT LESSENS
THE AMOUNT OF WATER WE PULL OUT
OF THE GROUND. WE HAVE NOT YOUR
GATED FROM AWHILE IN OVER
THIRTY YEARS SO I REALLY STRIVE
TO. WORK REGIONALLY WITH SOME
OF OUR CLAIM WASTE WATER
SYSTEMS. AND REALLY LOOK AT IS
THIS WATER SUSTAINABLE GOING TO
URBAN OR GOING UP FOR HYDRO
ELECTRICITY- HOW CAN ME
REVAMPED SOME OF OUR WATER
QUALITY. I'M RULES ON THE JERRY
SIDE- FOR YEARS IT WAS. YOU
KNOW SEND CLEAN WATER OFF THE
FARM- BUT HOW CAN WE CAPTURE
THAT RAIN WATER INTO. INTO OUR
DAMS. INTO SOMETHING- HOLDING
FACILITIES SO WE COULD UTILIZE
THAT BACK TOGETHER WASHER
CORRALS. OR WATER ANIMALS. AND
ALSO YOU KNOW TAKING DOWN SOME
OF THE RED TAPE WHEN WE THINK
ABOUT. CAN WE CLEAN OUT SOME OF
OUR DAMS THAT WE ALREADY HAVE
ON FARM. FOR EXAMPLE. ARE
DERIAN MORAN WERE LOOKING TO
CLEAN OR NOT CLEAN IT OUT TO
HAVE IT A LITTLE BIT. BIGGER
STORAGE JUST OVER THE YEARS
SETTLEMENT AND JULIE'S OUT OF
GROWN. AND ALSO- YOU KNOW JUST.
AS WELL AS SOME OF OUR MENU
UPON TALKING TO MAYBE TURN
THOSE INTO YOU OR BUILD NEW
ONES. BUILD NEW CASH MEANT FOR
WATER- AND ALSO REGIONAL
FUNDING WOULD BE GREAT- LET'S
BRING SOME OF THOSE FUNDS
REGIONALLY AND DO SOME GREAT
PROJECTS. ON WATER STORAGE.
THANK YOUNG MISS BRETT WOULD
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY AND- AS ALWAYS
APPRECIATE YOU JOINING US- I
KNOW YOUR FATHER WAS AT A- A
PREVIOUS HEARING OF OURS
EARLIER IN THE YEAR AND SO WE
REALLY APPRECIATE ALL THAT-
YOUR YOUR FAMILY DO A SECOND-
MEMBER THIS PANEL IS JEFF MAIN
WITH GOOD HOMINIS FARM JEFF IF
YOU WITH US- DAHLE YOURS YEAH
WE'RE HERE FIVE R. ONE
INTRODUCE YOU ALL TO MY
DAUGHTER WHO'S PART OF THE
TRANSITION OF OUR FARM FROM THE
FIRST GENERATION THE SECOND
GENERATION- AND SHE'LL START
PRESENTATION. YEAH FIVE WE WANT
TO FIRST THANK THE COMMITTEE
FOR A CONSIDERATION OF
TESTIMONY FROM CALIFORNIA SMALL
FAMILY FARMERS FACING THE
DIFFICULTIES OF FARMING WITH
DIMINISHING WATER RESOURCES AND
CLIMATE CHANGE WELL WE WANT TO
ALSO EXTEND OUR THANKS TO DAVE
RAMSDEN AND THE COMMUTER LINE
TO FAMILY FARMERS FROM BOTH THE
ADVOCACY AND SUPPORT THEY HAVE
PROVIDED OF THE LAST FORTY
YEARS. UP FOR SMALL FARMS
STATEWIDE AND FOR OF COURSE
REPRESENT- PRESENTING TODAY THE
PROPOSAL- TO GOVERNOR GOVERNOR
NEWSOM AND THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LEGISLATURE FOR RELIEF FUNDS
FOR FAMILY FARMERS WHOSE WORK
IS BEING THREATENED BY THE
DROUGHT WE ARE AWARE THAT OUR
TESTIMONY WILL NOT EVEN BEGIN
TO DESCRIBE THE BREADTH AND THE
DEPTH OF THE PHYSICAL AND
PSYCHOLOGICAL DAMAGE BEING DONE
TO OUR LOCAL ARM AND FOOD
COMMUNITIES BY THIS DROUGHT-
BUT WE FEEL IT'S IMPORTANT.
THAT WE APPEAR BEFORE YOU TODAY
BECAUSE OUR STORY IS RELEVANT-
AS PART OF A OF A MUCH BROADER
CRISIS SHE WAS AN INTEGRAL PART
OF THAT STORY- MY WIFE AND I
STARTED COULD YOU MUST PRODUCE-
FORTY SIX YEARS AGO. AND I NOW
COME TO THE- IN FRONT OF THE
COMMITTEE WITH A FORTY SIX YEAR
CAREER. ARE PRODUCING- ORGANIC
PRODUCE IN WESTERN HELLO COUNTY
WE I'M CURRENTLY A MEMBER OF A
FIVE PERSON FAMILY FARM
PARTNERSHIP.THAT NOW RUNS THE
BUSINESS OKAY ARE PRODUCING
ABOUT A HALF A MILLION DOLLARS
WORTH OF FRESH FRUIT FRESH
VEGETABLES AND FLOWERS FOR YOUR
COUNTY AND SACRAMENTO COUNTY
ALL OF OUR PRODUCE IS ARE
PRETTY IS PRETTY MUCH IN THOSE
TWO COUNTS ARE WE ALL DO THAT
WE DO THIS FROM A TWENTY ACRE
PARCEL IN WESTERN A LOT COUNTY
WHICH IS PART OF THE REASON WHY
WE'VE BEEN BROUGHT HERE TODAY.
JUST TO LET YOU KNOW ABOUT OUR
TIES TO THE COMMUNITY WHICH
ARE. ARE THE MOST IMPORTANT
PART OF OUR FARM IS WE'VE BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL IN IN. HELPING
START DAVIS FOOD COOP THE DAVIS
FARMERS MARKET IN WHICH WE'VE
SOLD FOR- FORTY SOME YEARS. AND
MY WIFE IS HAS BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL IN STARTING ON THE
YELLOW- ARTNET PROGRAM AND THE
YOLO COUNTY FARM TO SCHOOL
CHILDREN'S EDUCATIONAL PROGRAM
AN ESSENTIAL PART OF WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO AND THEY ARE AN
ESSENTIAL PART OF WIRE THAT
ILLUSTRATES OUR BELIEF IN THE
FUTURE CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE
FROM SMALL FARMERS IT IS THAT
WE HAVE- WITH THE SUPPORT OF
THE SACRAMENTO FOOD COOP THE
SUPPORT OF THE DAVIS FOOD COOP
IN SUPPORT OF LITERALLY
THOUSANDS OF CITIZENS IN THE
SACRAMENTO YOLO COUNTY AREA.
WE'VE BEEN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN PUT AN AFFIRMATIVE.
AGRICULTURAL EASEMENT ON OUR
LAND THAT CURRENTLY. MAKES IT
AVAILABLE FOR- THE NEXT
GENERATION OF FARMERS YEAH AND
MY RED TO BECOMING THE NEXT
GENERATION HEARING GOOD HUMUS-
BEGAN AFTER EIGHT YEARS ON THE
EAST COAST- AND I RETURNED TO
THE FARM TO CONTINUE MY PARENTS
WORK AND LAND STEWARDSHIP AND
FOOD PRODUCTION- I LIVED IN NEW
YORK I LIVED IN BOSTON BUT
REALLY FIND MYSELF YEARNING TO
BE BACK HERE- WITH THE LAND
AND- BEING A PART OF SOMETHING
THAT GIVES BACK TO THE PLANET.
AND THE PEOPLE HERE IN A REALLY
POSITIVE WAY- AND CONNECTING TO
THE COMMUNITY THAT I GREW UP
IN- WHICH IS LED BY
ENTREPRENEURS AND PEOPLE WHO
REALLY MOTIVATED TO REINVEST
THEIR PROFITS. IN THE FUTURE
FOR ALL OF US HERE- IT'S A
COMMUNITY OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE
TIME AND AGAIN- SEEING WHAT'S
HAPPENING AROUND US AND WORKED
REALLY REALLY HARD TO REIMAGINE
WHAT THE FUTURE CAN LOOK LIGHT.
I'M IN THAT IS SO IMPORTANT-
THEY DID THIS WITH THE ORGANIC
FOOD MOVEMENT IN THE SEVENTIES
THE LOCAL FOOD MOVEMENT IN THE
EARLY TWO THOUSANDS AND ARE
CURRENTLY BEING CONFRONTED WITH
THE CHALLENGES. OF FARMING AND
PRODUCING- IN THE FACE OF
EXTREME DROUGHT AND CLIMATE
CHANGE- SO YEAH THAT THAT TIME
WE REALLY MADE ME REALIZE HOW
UNIQUE FAMILY FARMS ARE AND
SMALL FAMILY FARMS AND THE
IMPACT OF THE WORK THAT THEY
CAN DO HERE ON THE GROUND AND
SO AND HOW IMPORTANT IT IS TO
INVEST IN THAT AND IN OUR
COMBAT SURVIVAL OF THOSE FARMS-
I RETURNED TO NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE I AM.
INVESTED IN CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE I RETURNED WITH THE
DREAM OF CONTINUING OUR WORK
HERE- FOR A SECOND GENERATION-
BUT TODAY WE REALLY FEEL THAT
FUTURE IS BEING THREATENED IT'S
BEING THREATENED BY THE
DROUGHT. BY CLIMATE CHANGE AND
BY INVESTMENT AGRICULTURE-
WHICH IS PUSHING FOR PROFIT
TODAY WITHOUT ANY CONSIDERATION.
WHATSOEVER- FOR WHAT TOMORROW
CAN BRING AND SO IT APPEARS
TODAY THAT MY FUTURE AND MY
FUTURE HERE GOOD HUMUS AND- IS
DEPENDENT ON THE ACTION FOR THE
LEADERSHIP. TO PRIORITIZE THE
NEEDS OF THE SMALL FAMILY FARM
HERE. RA I THINK YOU MAY WONDER
WHY WERE TALKIES SO MUCH OF OUR
COMMUNITY AND- THE NEEDS OF OUR
SMALL FARMERS BUT IT'S OUR IT'S
OUR BELIEF THAT THE DROP IN
ITSELF IS TERRIBLE BUT- THE
FORM THAT WE TAKE IN PRODUCING
THE FIRM THAT WE NEED FOR
CALIFORNIA AND FOR THE- AND FOR
THE INTERNATIONAL. THE FORM
THAT OUR AGRICULTURE TAKES IS
ESSENTIAL. IS ESSENTIAL TO WHAT
CALIFORNIA WILL LOOK LIKE IN
THE FUTURE IN THE LIGHT OF
THESE KIND OF DROUGHT
CONDITIONS SO WE YOU KNOW FOR
PERSONAL SITUATION WE FEEL LIKE
A FARM UNDER SIEGE RIGHT NOW.
WITH OUR WATER SITUATION SINCE
OUR DOMESTIC WELL WENT DRY A
COUPLE YEARS AGO WE'VE BEEN
RELYING ON OUR AGRICULTURAL
WELL TO PROVIDE WATER FOR BOTH
OUR DOMESTIC NEEDS AND OUR
CULTURAL NEEDS THERE AT THE
STATUS THAT AGRICULTURE WELL
IS. IS IN DANGER- AND WE ARE BY.
WE ARE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
FUTURE OF FUTURE POSSIBILITIES
OF THIS FARM IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN OUR WATER STOOD AT A
HUNDRED FEET BELOW GROUND WATER
BELOW GROUND LEVEL. RIGHT BY
THE END OF THE DIRE DROWNED IN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN INSTEAD OF
A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY ONE- FEET
BELOW GROUND LEVEL THIS BY
RIGHT AROUND TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN ANOTHER FACTOR
CAME INTO- INTO FOCUS I WANT
TO. TALK TO YOU IN A MOMENT BUT
THE LAST POINT OF REFERENCE FOR
OUR PARTICULAR ROLES WITHIN THE
LAST TWO MONTHS IS DROPPED
ANOTHER TWENTY FIVE FEET. WHICH
IS OUR OUR FULLY A QUARTER OF
WHAT IT DROPPED IN THE FIRST IN
THE LAST TWENTY YEARS THAT'S
THE RESULTS I'M SURE OF THIS
DROUGHT BUT ANOTHER THING OF
WHICH THERE WAS SOME
ENCOURAGING TO HEAR AT THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEMBER FROM
FARMS. OR HAS VERY LITTLE
AGRICULTURAL BACKGROUND. TALK
ABOUT- D. R. D. TYPE OF
AGRICULTURE THAT CALIFORNIA
MIGHT PRACTICE. THE GREATEST
DISAPPOINTMENT FOR US HAS BEEN
BE TOMORROW OR A WATER CRISIS
IN OUR AREA BY THE AGGRESSIVE
MULTINATIONAL INVESTMENT BY
AGRIBUSINESS CULTURE IT HAS
BEEN IMPOSSIBLE NOT TO NOTICE.
THAT THE LOWERING OUR OF OUR
WATER TABLE FROM THE COMBINED
EXTRACTIONS OF THE- MASSIVE
DEEP AND MASSIVE AGRICULTURAL
PUMPS THAT SERVICE THE
LITERALLY THOUSANDS OF ACRES
OF. ALMONDS OLIVES GRAPES AND
PISTACHIOS IN THE PREVIOUSLY
I'M HERE AGAIN LANDS BETWEEN
OFFICE AND COLUSA IN THE HILL
LANDS BETWEEN US AND COLUSA.
AND THAT UNFORTUNATELY LINE
RIGHT OVER THE SOURCE OF OUR
ACT OF THE Y. RIGHT IN THE
DIRECTION OF OUR AQUIFERS AS AN
INDICATOR. AS AN INDICATOR OF
THAT. OTHER PEOPLE ARE NOTICING
THIS WE'VE BEEN TOLD THAT THERE
IS A CRIED BUT- THERE'S A
PROVIDE A PRIVATE PROPOSAL IN
FRONT OF A LOCAL GOVERNING
WATER BOARD. TO PROVIDE WATER
TO HUNDREDS OF ACRES OF
CURRENTLY I NEAR GATED LAND THE
TO THAT WILL BE DEVELOPED
THROUGH A PIPELINE FROM AN
EXISTING SOURCE THAT WILL THEN
BE DEVELOPED FOR THE FURTHER.
ON PLANTING OF OLIVES AND
GRAPES IN OUR AREA NOW WE ALL I
THINK WE ALL CAN UNDERSTAND THE
ARM REST WITH WHICH WE BELIEVE
THAT THIS IS NOT GOING TO HAVE
AN IMPACT ON OUR- GROUNDWATER
SYSTEM WE'RE ALL FAMILIAR WITH.
SOUTHERN SAN WALKING EVEN IN
OTHER AREAS. SO THIS WHAT WHAT
WE SEE HERE ARE HAPPENING
AROUND US IS KIND OF REALLY
SIMILAR TO OUR MANY POINTS IN
CALIFORNIA HISTORY WERE SMALL
FARMS SMALL FAMILY FARMS HOUSE
THEIR SURVIVAL HAS BEEN
DEPENDENT ON FACTORS IN POWERS
MUCH LARGER THAN THEY THEN
THERE'S- AND THIS SEEMS LIKE TO
BE PARTICULARLY TRUE AT THIS
TIME THE POWER ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE FENCE IS ON THE FENCE IS
BEYOND ALMOST BEYOND OUR
ABILITY TO COMPREHEND THE SMALL
FARMERS. BUT WHAT THAT'S WHY WE
DEPEND ON PEOPLE WHITE THE
COMMITTEES THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE AND AN ADVANCED
ADVOCACY GROUPS LIKE THE
COMMUNITY ALLIANCE FOR FAMILY
FARMERS THAT KEEP OUR ISSUES IN
FRONT OF YOUR WE DEPEND ON THEM
SO WE'RE ASKING- THE COMMITTEES
AND THE LEGISLATURE TO TAKE UP
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE. US
ARE A FEW MOMENTS OF RESPITE
FOR SMALL FARMERS AS WE TRY TO
GET THROUGH THEY REALLY DRASTIC
REDUCTIONS IN WATER
AVAILABILITY. THAT WE'RE WE'RE
SEEING ON IN FRONT OF US NOW.
THANK YOU YEAH YEAH SKEWS ME IN
CONCLUSION WE JUST WANTED TO
THANK THE COMMITTEES AGAIN FOR
YOUR TIME AND PATIENCE IN
HEARING OUR TESTIMONY. AND HOPE
THAT WE HAVE ADDED TO THE CASE
FOR THE MAINTENANCE AND SUPPORT
OF FARMING POPULATIONS THAT
SERVER THAT ARE PART OF THE
LOCAL COMMUNITIES AND ECONOMIES
IN CALIFORNIA HERE- AND HOPE
THAT WE HAVE VERY CLEARLY
STATED THAT THE REQUESTED
FUNDING IS ESSENTIAL IS
ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL AS A-
TEMPORARY MEASURE THAT WILL
KEEP WATER FLOWING. ONTO THE
FARMS THAT GROW IN THE FUTURE-
THAT YOU AND EVERY CITIEN OF
CALIFORNIA- SHOULD BE ABLE TO
EAT TONIGHT THANK YOU. THANKS
FOR THAT TESTIMONY AND- ALL THE
INFORMATION OUR NEXT PANELIST
DANIEL HARTWIG WITH WOLF
FARMING LOCATED FRESNO THE
DANIEL IF YOU'RE WITH US YOU
MAY BEGIN THANK YOU ARE
CHAIRMAN RIVAS AND- THEY COULD
SHARE GARCIA'S FALL FOR THIS I
HEARING I STATED I'M DANIEL
HARTWIG AND I WORK FOR WILL
FARMING I'M ALSO THE- PRESIDENT
OF THE FRESNO COUNTY FARM
BUREAU- THE BATTLE BACKGROUND
ABOUT OUR FARMING OPERATION I
WAS STARTED BY JACK WALKED IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR IT'S A
FAMILY. OWNED AND OPERATED
FARM- AS STATED PREVIOUSLY
LOCATED ON THE WEST SIDE OF
FRESNO COUNTY. OUR GROWERS OF
TOMATOES ALMONDS PISTACHIOS
GARLIC- COTTON I LIVE IN A WEAK
MOMENT WHEN THERE'S WATER-
WHICH- AND RIGHT NOW THAT'S THE
THAT'S A LITTLE BIT TRICKY- BUT
PREVIOUSLY YOUR PREVIOUS TO
BEING ABLE TO GROW THOSE CROPS-
WE WERE YOUNG. WE WERE BEFORE
THE C. B. P. WAS DEVELOPED THE
CENTRAL VALLEY PROJECT- THE
OTHER GROWERS ON THE WEST SIDE
OF THE VALLEY WERE WERE LIMITED
TO GROWING YOU KNOW COTTON-
GRAIN CROPS IN A LITTLE BIT OF
BALANCES WELL- YOU KNOW THE
IMPORTANCE OF SERVICE WATER
DELIVERIES TO OUR REGION CAN'T
BE- CAN'T BE OVERSTATED. THE
SERVICE WATER DELIVERIES YOU
KNOW REALLY ALLOW US TO GROW
THESE HIGH VALUE CROPS- THAT-
THAT REALLY SUPPORT YOUR NUMBER
OF JOBS AND SUPPORT A LOT OF
SMALL COMMUNITIES AS WELL. WELL
FORMING THE CERTIFIED B. CORP
LIKE TO TALK A BIT ABOUT THE
SUSTAINABILITY PORTION OF
THINGS- YEAH WE'RE CERTIFIED B.
CORP MEANING THAT WE MEASURE
AND EVALUATE OUR DECISIONS
BASED ON SUSTAINABILITY AND YOU
KNOW. MAKING SURE THEY WERE
MAKING OUR DECISIONS THAT ARE
BASED ON FACTORS LIKE THE
COMMUNITY- FACT LIKE OUR WATER
USE FACTORS LIKE OUR WASTE-
FACTORS LIKE OUR EMISSIONS AND
THINGS LIKE THAT- WE WORK
REALLY HARD TO- TO MAKE SURE
THE WORTH OF VISIONS POSSIBLE
WITH THOSE. ARE TALKING A BIT
ABOUT THIS YEAR'S CONDITIONS
OUT WE STARTED OUT WITH A WITH
WHAT WAS A 5% WATER ALLOCATION
OF SURFACE WATER- YOU WHICH
WASN'T HURT MUCH WHEN YOU'RE
ONLY WHEN YOU'RE ONLY ALLOWED
ABOUT TWO AND A HALF FEET OF
WATER- FROM ITS SURFACE WATER.
DELIVERIES- BUT THEN THAT WOULD
I THOUGHT ZERO. AND YOUR MOM AT
THAT CREATES A LOT OF PROBLEMS
ZERO WATER MEANS WE HAVE TO
RELY ON OUR ARMED YOUR STAVING
ACCOUNT AS LECTURER FOR TO OUR
TO OUR AQUIFER'S I REFER TO AS
A SAVINGS ACCOUNT BECAUSE-
REALLY YOU KNOW THE SURFACE
WATER LIKE A CHECKING ACCOUNT
LIKE REVENUE THAT'S COMING IN
EVERY MONTH- AND THEN SOMETIMES
WHEN THAT WHEN THAT FALL SHORT
YOU HAVE TO TURN TO YOUR TO
YOUR SAVINGS ACCOUNTS- BUT WITH
CIGNA COMING AND THAT THAT'S
THAT'S GOING TO BE- A HUGE
CHALLENGE FOR US OTHERS CAN BE
A LOT LESS THAN THAT SAVINGS
ACCOUNT AS WELL- WE FOUND OUT
WE WERE GETTING ZERO WATER- THE
OBVIOUSLY LOOKED AT TO TRY TO
GET MORE. YOU KNOW WATER
TRANSFERS- TO COME IN- YOUNG
AND SEEING IF ANYBODY OUTSIDE
OUR WATER DISTRICT MIGHT HAVE
WANTED TO WE COULD BRING IN-
BUT THERE WAS NO FLEXIBILITY
THERE THERE'S VERY LITTLE YOU
KNOW WATER- LIQUIDITY- SO TO
SPEAK- THAN THAT WITHIN THE
MARKET. AND THAT WILL WATER
THERE WAS- IT'S JUST SELLING
FOR UNSUSTAINABLE RATES YOU
CAN'T GROW CROP ON ON TWO
THOUSAND DOLLAR WATER IT'S JUST
ON FEASIBLE- IN THE END THERE
WAS NO LIKE I SAID NO NO REALLY
ABILITY WITHIN THE STATE SYSTEM
AS WELL TO- TO BRING IN OTHER
WATER EVEN WITH THE DROUGHT
DECLARATION IN MAY- WHICH
BASICALLY WHICH WHICH LEADS
WHICH LED US TO- TO THE FACT OF
HAVING TO PULL OUT ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED ACRES OF ALMONDS. WE
MADE THAT DECISION- BACK IN
APRIL AND WE HAD TO MAKE THAT
DECISION AND IT WASN'T AS WE
MADE EARLY ON- BUT WE KNEW IF
WE HAD TO TRY TO- IF THOSE
TREES THIS YEAR- WE WOULDN'T
HAVE ENOUGH WATER TO IRRIGATE
THE REST OF OUR TREES IN THE
REST OF OUR OUR CROPS ARE
TOMATOES IN OUR COLUMN. I
THINGS LIKE THAT- WE JUST
WOULDN'T HAVE ENOUGH WATER TO
BE ABLE TO DO THAT- WHAT WE
PULLED OUR FIFTEEN YEAR OLD
TREES- AND I'M SURE AS IF
ANYBODY'S FAMILIAR WITH THAT-
ALMONDS GO FOR ABOUT TWENTY
FIVE YEARS WHICH MEANS WE GIVE
UP- YOU KNOW A LOT OF THE
PEOPLE DUCTION IN THESE TREES.
ARE. KNOWN FUTURE REVENUE BOB
THE THEY'RE JUST WASN'T WATER
AND IT WHICH IS BETTER WITH THE
REST OF OPEN I TO LEAVE HIS
THINGS IN THE YOU KNOW AS FAR
AS MAKING THE FOR NOW YOU KNOW
WE'RE LOOKING AT NEXT YEAR IS
BEING ANOTHER 0% YEAR- WERE
WERE MAKING YOU KNOW MAKING OUR
ASSUMPTIONS ON HOW MUCH WE CAN
PLANTS- FACTORING INTO WE HAVE
NO WATER- NO SURFACE WATER
COMING IN. AND WERE YOU KNOW
LOOKING AT IT FROM THE
STANDPOINT THAT SIGMOD NEW
IMPLEMENTATION STARTS NEXT YEAR
FOR US AS WELL. ASSORTMENT
HAVEN'T MAKE A LOT OF HARD
DECISIONS IN TERMS OF WHAT
CROSS WE CAN GROW AND HOW MUCH
WE CAN GROW AS WELL- AND AGAIN
THAT HAS A HUGE OF IMPACT ON ON
JOBS- NOT ONLY ON OUR OWN. YOU
KNOW ON THE FARM ITSELF BUT IN
A IN THE PROCESSING OPERATIONS-
THAT ARE ALL THAT YOU KNOW
THAT. YOUR DOCTOR THE YOU KNOW
THE FORMED THIS WELL- ANYTIME
THAT CROPS ARE ABLE TO BE
GROUND. THERE'S DOWNSTREAM
IMPACTS- THERE WAS NO ANSWER
AND IT WILL LOOK TO THE FUTURE
OF NEXT YEAR AS WELL AS I DRIVE
AROUND THE WEST SIDE I SEE A
LOT OF TREES THAT- DIDN'T GET
VERY MUCH WATER THIS YEAR. I
DIDN'T GET SAID- DEFINITELY GET
ENOUGH WATER AND I AM AN AWFUL
LOT OF GROWERS- OR THINKING
ABOUT EITHER GET FULL
INDUSTRIES OUT THIS UPCOMING
YEAR. OR IF THEY'RE- YOU KNOW
JUST DEFICIT HERE GETTING INTO
THE TO THE POINT TO JUST BARELY
KEEP THE THING ALIVE BUT- BUT
THERE'S GONNA BE A SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT TO HOW MUCH YOU KNOW
WHAT. THE HOME CROWD LOOKS LIKE
THE YEAR AND EXTRA AS WELL I'M
THINKING ABOUT THE SALUTE YEAH
I WAS KIND OF HARDENED IT TO
HERE I AM DURING THE FIRST
PANEL OF THE YOU KNOW THE
CONCEPT OF RECHARGE- RECHARGES
IS A HUGE HUGE THING FOR ACROSS
HERE IN THE IN THE SOUTHERN
SILICON VALLEY- BECAUSE WHEN
THAT WATER DOES COME. AYE WE IT
COMES IN HUGE FLOCKS AND WE'VE
GOT TO BE ABLE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO
PULL THE WATER OUT OF. RIVERS
AND STREAMS IS THERE ANYONE IS
THERE YOU KNOW TURNING AND
GOING AND MONDAY'S HEAVY STORMS
AND ABLE TO STORE THAT WATER-
BELOW GROUND ESPECIALLY THROUGH
THROUGH RECHARGE PROJECTS- AS
WELL AS SOME OF THE WATER
THROUGH THE- THROUGH YOU KNOW
THROUGH THE DELTA AMPLE YOU
KNOW POINT OUT THROUGH. THE
CALIFORNIA AQUEDUCT AND OTHER
ADVANCES WELL- IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR US TO BE ABLE TO
RECHARGE OF GROUNDWATER IN THE
IN THE YEARS WE HAVE THAT COULD
FLOW- THE OTHER PIECE WITH THE
ABOVE GROUND STORAGE AS WELL I
NEED THAT WE JUST NEED TO BE
ABLE TO CAPTURE MORE MORE THAT
WATER. WHEN IT'S AVAILABLE-
YEAH I THINK WE TALKED A LOT
ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE- YEAH WE
TALK ABOUT THE WATER IS GOIN
TO COME DOWN YEAH MORE AS RAIN-
THAT MEANS WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
HAVE MORE STORAGE TO BE ABLE TO
CAPTURE THAT IT'S NOT GONNA
FALL IT'S NOT GONNA MELT SNOW
MELTS AS IT HAS IN THE PAST SO
WE HAVE TO YOU. TAKE DIFFERENT
SAID TAKE A DIFFERENT TACK TO
ME OUT OF PREVIOUSLY I JUST I
LIKE TO SEE A MORE COOPERATION
BETWEEN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
STATE ARE USING SNOW SCIENCE
BASED APPROACH AS WELL- YEAH. I
WAS REALLY SAD TO SEE THE STATE
YOU KNOW SUE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT- YOU KNOW WHAT THE
BIOLOGICAL OPINIONS- WHEN THOSE
OPINIONS OUR LEAD ARE TAKING
MORE SCIENCE BASED APPROACH
RATHER THAN A CALENDAR BASED
APPROACH- TO LOOKING AT- YOU
KNOW HOW MUCH WATER CAN BE
MOVED THROUGH THE DELTA THROUGH
THE PUMPS THERE- YOU KNOW WHEN
I'M PERFORMING I MAKING
DECISIONS ON. YOUR ASIAN I'M
LOOKING AT YOU KNOW SOIL
MOISTURE DATA I'M LOOKING AT MY
TREES YEAH LOOK AT THE STRESS
THERE- I'M LOOKING A WHOLE.
HOST OF DIFFERENT FACTORS NO
FUTURE WHETHER AND I'M TAKING
ALL THOSE IN THE CAN I DO JUST
LOOK AT A CALENDAR AND SAY WELL
IT'S YOU KNOW AUGUST TWENTY- I
SHOULD MODERN THE TREES ITS YOU
KNOW IT'S A DIFFERENT IT'S THAT
MUCH MORE SCIENCE BASED
APPROACH. I'M NOT SPREAD OUT
THE SEEDS FROM- FROM THE FROM
THE STATE THE FEDERAL. SAYS
THERE. SO THAT'S THAT'S ALL I
HAVE TO SAY ON THE ON THIS- AND
I'LL TAKE IT BUT LATER ON BUT I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
PRESENTS INFORMATION. THANK YOU
MISTER HART WE WERE REALLY DAY
TEST AND OUR FINAL PANELIST IS
VICKY ESPINOZA BUT THE UC
MERCED VIC IF YOU'RE WITH US
YOU MAY BEGIN. I THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME TODAY- MY NAME STICKY
ESPINOZA I'M A PHD CANDIDATE AT
UC MERCED AND ON THE WORK THAT
I'M DOING FOR MY DISSERTATION
IS TO DEVELOP A LANDER
PURPOSING MODEL THAT
INCORPORATES AGRICULTURAL
COMMUNITY INPUT IN ORDER TO
MINIMIZE- IMPACTS TO OUR
COMMUNITIES AND SMALL SCALE
GROWERS I'VE ALSO DEVELOPED A
TRILINGUAL CHANNEL CALLED
COUNTY WATER AG. AND IT'S FOR
OUR COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND
GROWERS TO REALLY LEARN ABOUT
POLICIES LIKE CIGNA AND IT
REALLY HELPS EXPLAIN THE
SCIENCE AND POLICY BEHIND
CALIFORNIA WATER AND
AGRICULTURE. SO TODAY I'D LIKE
TO BEGIN WITH JUST A BRIEF
REVIEW OF THE TWENTY TWELVE TO
TWENTY SIXTEEN DROUGHT IMPACTS
FOR SMALL SCALE FARMERS IN
CALIFORNIA AND I'D LIKE TO GIVE
CREDIT TO RUTH DAHLQUIST
WILLARD WITH UC AGRICULTURE AND
NATURAL RESOURCES. SO SHE
CONDUCTED A SURVEY OF SIXTY
EIGHT SOUTH EAST ASIAN FARMERS
AND. FRESNO. AND SO SOME OF THE
IMPACTS THAT WERE SEEN IN TERMS
OF IMPACTS TO SMALL SCALE
FARMERS WERE. SHALLOW WELLS
GOING DRY- A LOT OF THE FARMERS
AND FRESNO AREA APPROXIMATELY
96% OF THOSE FARMERS THAT WERE.
SURVEYED RELY ON GROUNDWATER
ENTIRELY SUGGEST LARGE SCALE
IMPACTS INCLUDE LOSS OF WELLS
ESPECIALLY SHALLOW WELLS-
SHALLOW WELLS CAN TO GO FIRST.
AND SHALLOW WELLS ARE OFTEN-
OWNED BY A SMALL PORTABLE FARMS
THAT DON'T HAVE THE MONEY OR
THE RESOURCES TO DIG DEEPER
WELLS OTHER ON IMPACTS WERE
REDUCED WATER AVAILABILITY TO
EVERY KEEP CROPS AND HIGHER
ENERGY COSTS FOR GROUNDWATER
PUMPING OR JUST OTHER
OPERATIONS ON THE FARM AND THIS
IS ALSO THIS STUDY ALSO FOUND
POTENTIAL MENTAL HEALTH
CONSEQUENCES WITH HAVING TO
DEAL WITH- SURFACE WATER OF
REDUCTION AS WELL AS HAVING TO
DEAL WITH- MEETING. THOSE
RESTRICTIONS THAT ARE BEING SAT
ON SOME OF OUR SMALL SCALE
FARMERS IN TERMS OF WATER USE.
AS WELL AS IMPACTS FOR FOOD
SECURITY NOT ONLY FOR THE
NATION AND THE STATE BUT FOR
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE SAMPSON COUNTY
TRANSICOLD SEE RECOMMENDATIONS-
I'VE PERSONALLY HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH
SEVERAL SMALL SCALE FARMERS
THROUGHOUT MY- DOCTORAL
RESEARCH HERE EASY MERCED. A
LOT OF WHAT I HAVE BEEN SEEING
HAS BEEN DEALING WITH
INFORMATION EQUITY EQUITY AND
ACCESSIBILITY- SO I HIGHLY
RECOMMEND AND WOULD LOVE TO SEE
MORE FUNDING FOR INFORMATION
BEING DEVELOPED IN NON ENGLISH
LANGUAGES- THERE ARE A LOT OF
MANGA AND CELESTINO FARMERS IN
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY. AS WELL
AS OTHER ETHNICITIES THAT ARE
PRESENT IN THE STATE AND SOME
OF THESE FARMERS DON'T HAVE THE
SUPPORT FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE IN TERMS OF- BEING
ABLE TO ACCESS FUNDING OR
REALLY GETTING THAT HELP THAT
THEY NEED IN ORDER TO APPLY FOR
FUNDING THAT IS AVAILABLE. AT
THE STATE LEVEL AND EVEN AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL. IN TERMS OF-
SERVICES FOR OUR SMALL SCALE
GROWERS OFFERING MORE
TIGHTENING LEGAL- OR BILINGUAL
SERVICES AND STAFF THAT ARE
ABLE TO ATTEND MEETINGS TO HELP
TRANSLATE THE MATERIAL SO THAT
ARE SMALL SCALE FARMERS THAT
DON'T SPEAK ENGLISH CAN ALSO BE
AWARE OF WHAT'S GOING ON AND BE
A PART OF THAT CONVERSATION IN
TERMS OF MAKING DECISIONS FOR
THEIR FOR THEIR FUTURE IN TERMS
OF FINDING- SOME OF THESE ARE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT DOCTOR
BOTH DOCTORS WILLARD HAS ALSO
EXPRESSED WITH ME AND HAS ALSO
WRITTEN A POLICY BRIEF THAT
WILL BE PBLISHED SOON- SO SOME
OF THE FUNDING COULD BE FOR ONE
MEDICATION PROGRAMS FOR DIRECT
RELIEF TO SMALL SCALE FARMERS-
ESPECIALLY FARMERS MEETING TO
DEEPEN WELL OR CHILDREN WHILE.
THAT MAY BE COMPLICATED WITH
SIGMA BUT- I THINK IT'S
SOMETHING TO CONSIDER IN TERMS
OF REALLY EXPANDING FUNDING TO
INCLUDE SMALL SCALE FARMERS AND
MAKE ADJUSTMENTS SO THAT THESE
ARE TAILORED MORE TOWARD THAT
SMALL FARMER ON ENVIRONMENT AND
SITUATIONS FUNDING FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF CONSERVATION
TECHNOLOGY WORK ON CONSERVATION
TECHNOLOGY I'VE SPOKEN TO A LOT
OF SMALL SCALE GROWERS THAT ARE
INTERESTED IN IMPLEMENTING
TECHNOLOGY SUCH AS DRIP
IRRIGATION BUT THEY JUST DON'T
HAVE THE FINANCIAL MEANS TO DO
SO AT THE MOMENT ESPECIALLY
WHEN DEALING WITH DROUGHT AND
WATER SHORTAGES AND HAVING TO
TRANSITION TO OTHER
CONSERVATION TECHNOLOGY IS JUST
NOT FINANCIALLY FEASIBLE FOR
THEM AT THE MOMENT AS WELL AS-
ZERO INTEREST LOANS FOR WELL
DRILLING FOR SMALL SCALE
FARMERS AND I WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO EXTEND THIS FOR TECHNOLOGY
THAT COULD HELP SAVE WATER DOWN
THE LINE FOR OUR SMALL SCALE
FARMERS THERE IS ONE
RECOMMENDATION IN TERMS OF-
SPECIFICALLY TOWARD THE STATE
WATER EFFICIENCY ENHANCEMENT
PROGRAM OR THE SWEET PROGRAM.
TO INCLUDE LOWER INCOME SHOPS
AND DRILLING ON A DEEPER.
PROGRAMS FOR DOMESTIC FALL
IMPROVEMENTS AND TO SUPPORT
BUSINESSES DOMESTIC WELLS. TO
IRRIGATE SMALL ACREAGES IN
TERMS OF- ENERGY EFFICIENCY OF
THEIR PASSED OR REQUEST A
RECOMMENDATION TO. TALK TO PG&E
OR WORK SOMETHING OUT WITH PG&E
AND OTHER ELECTRIC COMPANIES TO
MAKE PROFICIENCY REBATES ON ALL
BUILT FINANCES IT'S MORE
ACCEPTABLE FOR SMALL SCALE
FARMERS AND AGAIN OFFERING
BILINGUAL OR MULTI LINGUAL
SERVICES ESPECIALLY WHEN
EXPLAINING THESE TYPES OF
PROGRAMS SO THAT THEY CAN
UNDERSTAND WHAT IS PART OF THAT
CONTRACT AND- FUNDS FUNDING I
BELIEVE THAT'S ALL I HAVE FOR
NOW BUT- I ALSO HAVE- TWO
OTHER. AND LIVED EXPERIENCES
FROM SMALL SCALE FARMERS IN
QUARTERFINAL AND FRESNO IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO HEAR THOSE. WELL
HERE WHAT HAPPENED SHARES
CLOSED I'M STILL DOESN'T ACTOR
ROBERT IMPORTER BILL WHO
ACTUALLY GOT IS- ALLOCATION
CERTAIN WATER ACT OF OFF. SHORE
JANET LEIGH THIS. GROWER WAS
ABLE TO. FOR OUT A TRANSIT IN
TERMS OF PURCHASING WATER FROM
THEIR NEIGHBOR WHO HAS A LARGER
PLOT OF LAND- SO THEY WERE
FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO DO THAT
THIS ISN'T THE CASE FOR EVERY
SINGLE FARMER OUT THERE. A LOT
OF SMALL SCALE GROWERS. AND
THEY JUST MAY NOT HAVE THE
MEANS OR THE CONNECTIONS TO
OTHERS THAT MAY BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THEM WITH SURFACE WATER
ALLOCATIONS THAT ARE SURPLUS
FOR OTHER GROWERS THIS GROWER
WAS INTERESTED IN CONVERTING
WATER SINCE- CONVERTING THEIR
WATER SYSTEM FROM SPRAY
MEASURES TO DRIP IRRIGATION.
BUT THEY CURRENTLY CANNOT
AFFORD. THAT TRANSITION TO NEW
TECHNOLOGY THERE'S A MIXED
VEGGIE FARMER IN FRESNO AND
CORRECTOR. AND WHO IS GROUND
WATER RELIANT AND SO WHEN THEY
WERE LOOKING TO EXPAND THEIR
OPERATIONS THEY FOUND THAT-
THERE WELL THE WELL OF THE LAND
THAT THEY HAD JUST PURCHASED
WHICH IS ABOUT TEN ACRES. WAS
ABOUT TEN FEET ABOVE THE WATER
TABLE SO THE PUMP WASN'T
REACHING THE GROUND WATER THAT
THEY NEEDED TO START THIS
OPERATION- THEY HAD ALREADY
SPENT THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS IN
PURCHASING LAND AS WELL AS
OTHER COSTS THAT ARE ASSOCIATED
WITH. YOU KNOW STARTING A SMALL
SCALE FARM AND THEY WERE ALSO
INTERESTED IN PURCHASING-
EFFICIENT IRRIGATION SO THAT
THEY CAN START. THEIR
OPERATIONS EFFICIENTLY AND
CONSERVING WATER AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE BUT THE FUNDS JUST
AREN'T PAYING OR THE MEANS FOR
THEM TO FINANCIALLY AFFORD
THESE TRANSITIONS. ARE
IMPLEMENTATION OF TECHNOLOGY IS
NOT THERE. ON THAT IS ALL I
WILL SAY FOR NOW BUT I THINK
FOUND. AS WE'RE FACED WITH THIS
DROUGHT AND- EVEN WITH THE
GROUNDWATER OVERDRAFT ISSUE
NETWORK BASED IN THE STATE.
THERE IS A LOT- OF- NEED TO BE
THERE FOR SMALL SCALE FARMERS
IN TERMS OF MAKING INFORMATION
ACCESSIBLE TO THEM IN MULTIPLE
LANGUAGES SO THAT EVERYONE CAN
MOVE FORWARD TOGETHER. AND
ADDRESSES GROUNDWATER OVERDRAFT
AND WATER MANAGEMENT TOGETHER.
I THINK THAT MOVING FORWARD IN
TERMS OF DROUGHT- IT WOULD BE
BENEFICIALTO SPEAK WITH-
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE WORKING
DIRECTLY WITH OUR FARMERS WITH
OUR SMALL SCALE GROWERS. SO
THAT THE SOLUTIONS THAT ARE
BEING DEVELOPED. REFLECT THE
NEEDS OF OUR GROWERS SO THAT WE
CAN ADDRESS WATER MANAGEMENT
AND MINDLESS MANAGEMENT IN THE
ONE THAT. DOESN'T NEGATIVELY
IMPACT THEM BUT EFFECTIVELY
ADDRESSES. THEIR NEEDS FOR THE
FUTURE THANK YOU END AND THEY
CAN ASSIST AS APPRECIATE ALL
THE INFORMATION AT THIS TIME
ALL WILL TURN OVER TO MEMBERS.
AND COLLEAGUES WITH ANY
QUESTIONS. MISS AGUIAR-CURRY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND FOR SO
I WANT TO THANK MY CONSTITUENTS
FROM CAPE FEAR VALLEY. AND I
CAN AGREE WITH THE MORE WE'VE
SEEN THAT BEFORE VALLEY JUST
GROW AND FLOURISH BUT- IT'S
REALLY TAKEN AWAY FROM THE
ABILITY TO GET FOUR MORE WATER.
AND WITH A LACK OF WATER DOWN
CACHE CREEK AND FROM LAKE
COUNTY- IT'S BEEN A VERY
TROUBLESOME FOR MANY OF US- BUT
I DO WANT TO JUST MAKE A
COMMENT- TO OUR YOUNG LADY FROM
UC MERCED- I PUT TOGETHER SOME
POLICY AND IS WORKING QUITE
WELL THROUGH CDFA. THIS CALL
THE DISADVANTAGED FAMILY PART
OF FARMERS AND IS A PROGRAM
THAT HELPS FARMERS IN DIFFERENT
LANGUAGES PARTICULAR TECHNICAL
EXPERTISE UNDERSTANDING AND HOW
TO WORK THE SYSTEM BECAUSE AS
WE KNOW IT'S NOT EASY TO BE A
FARMER WE- DEMAND SO MUCH FROM
THEM TO DO- ALL THE REGULATORY
INFORMATION- YOU KNOW TRYING TO
HELP FIND FUNDING SO I WOULD
JUST RECOMMEND THAT THROUGH
CDFA THEY ACTUALLY HAVE ONE
WOMAN WHO IS. DOING AN
INCREDIBLE JOB WORKING WITH OUR
DISADVANTAGED FAMILY FARMER
SOME OF THAT'S ONE THING. WITH
HEALTHY SOILS- HALF OF SO MANY
REAL GOOD THIS OF THE THINGS IS
HARD TO MANEUVER THE SYSTEM AND
UNDERSTAND THEM. SO I JUST
WANTED TO SHARE THAT. WANTED TO
SHARE THOSE THAT- BEEN A SMALL
FAMILY FARMER LIKE I AM AND THE
ONES WE'VE HEARD TODAY IT'S
DIFFICULT. AND WE NEED TO NOT
PUT SO MUCH- YOU KNOW IF YOU'RE
A BIG CORPORATION YOU HAVE A
LOT OF OTHER ASSETS. WHEN YOUR
SMALL FAMILY FARM YOU'RE JUST
TRYING TO MAKE ENDS MEET. AND A
FIX OF PUMP WE'VE HAD TWO PUMPS
GO OUT THIS YEAR AND THEY WERE
SO EXPENSIVE. AND TO FIND
SOMEBODY TO COME REPAIR THEM
AND REALLY DIRE TIME IT'S
ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE. AND THE COST
OF THAT IS CAN JUST TURN YOUR
WHOLE YEAR UPSIDE DOWN IN THE
BLINK OF AN EYE SO- I FEEL YOUR
PAIN I UNDERSTAND AND NOW WE
HAVE A LOT MORE WORK TO DO AND
I'M HOPING. WE HAVE SOME
OUTCOMES FROM THESE MEETINGS
WE'VE HAD HIM YEAR AFTER YEAR
AND I DON'T FEEL LIKE WE HAVE A
LOT OF OUTCOMES AND SO. IT'S
OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO HELP OUR
FARMERS ARE SMALL FAMILY
FARMERS AND THE PEOPLE. AND I
WANT TO FORGET THE PEOPLE THAT
ARE INVOLVED WITH THIS RIGHT WE
HAVE FAMILIES AND SMALL
COMMUNITIES OF. ALL OF US ARE
AFFECTED BY THIS IN A RURAL
AREA SO AGAIN THANK YOU ALL FOR
SHARING YOUR STORIES TODAY AND-
LET'S HOPEFULLY WE CAN GET
SOMETHING OUT OF THIS TODAY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHAT. YES SIR
THANK YOU THANK YOU TO OUR
CHAIRS AGAIN- AND THANK YOU TO
OUR PANELISTS I JUST- YOU KNOW
I'M SITTING HERE I'M REALLY
STRUCK BY THE- THE STORIES AND
THE PASSION FOR WHICH- OUR
FARMERS ARE APPROACHING THEIR
THEIR LIVELIHOOD AND WHAT IT
MEANS WHAT IT MEANS TO THEM AND
IT IS- IT IT'S HARD TO NOT FEEL
LITTLE HEART BROKEN WHEN YOU
SEE HOW DIFFICULT IT IS THIS
YEAR AND THE CHALLENGES THAT
THAT THAT EVERYONE IS FACING. I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
RECOGNIZE THOSE THAT ARE DOING-
THE VERY BEST THEY CAN IN THE
RIGHT THING- AND RECOGNIZE ALSO
THAT- OFTEN IN THIS BUILDING WE
DO A LOT OF ONE SIZE FITS ALL
LEGISLATION THAT DOESN'T
NECESSARILY REFLECT THE NEEDS.
AND THE CONCERNS OF SMALLER A
SMALLER FARMERS ON THE MY
DISTRICT- THE NORTH COAST WE
DON'T HAVE A LOT OF THESE
MASSIVE FARMS REALLY DOWN- WE
HAVE A LOT OF SMALL FARMERS IT
IS IT IS IT IS A FEELING MOSTLY
SMALL FARMERS AS A BIGGER
ENTITIES OF GROWING GRAPES BY
THE FURTHER NORTH YOU GO THE
LESS YOU SEE OF THAT. AND JUST
YOU KNOW THINKING WE ALSO RELY
ON RAIN WATER IN STORAGE- FOR
WE DON'T THERE'S NO SNOW MELT-
IN THE DISTRICT- THAT THAT
SUPPLIES OF WATER FOR- FOR
APPLES AND PEARS AND GRAPES AND
LEAFY CROPS AND- AND FOR
DAIRIES- AND SO IT IS IT IS
DIFFERENT AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE AS A BODY
RECOGNIZE THE DIFFERENCES IN
REGIONS. THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
AND THE CHALLENGES THAT THAT
THAT THAT THAT THEY FACE AND WE
APPROACH THAT- IN A IN A WAY
THAT DOESN'T THAT ONE SIZE FITS
ALL I THINK OF- THE HEALTHY
SOILS PROGRAM FOR EXAMPLE WE
HAVE A MORE FOR PHARMA I'LL PUT
A PLUG IN BECAUSE I I'M PUT
THEIR NAME OUT THERE FORTUNATE
FARMS. OVER IN MENDOCINO
COUNTY- THEY SEQUESTER HUGE
AMOUNTS OF CARBON IN THE SOIL-
BASED ON THEIR FARMING
PRACTICES. AND AND YOU KNOW
HEARING FROM. OUR FOLKS FROM
THE HUMANS FARM HOW DIFFICULT
IT IS SOMETIMES YOU GET SOME OF
THE FUNDING. THAT THAT THEY
THEY BELIEVE THAT THEY ARE YOU
KNOW IT SHOULD BE GETTING-
BECAUSE IT TAKES A LONG TIME IS
REALLY REALLY HEARTBREAKING ON
ON TOP OF HEARTBREAK BECAUSE
IT'S REALLY REALLY DIFFICULT.
AND WE DO THAT IN A VARIETY OF
AREAS AT THE STATE LEVEL SO- I
JUST WANTED KNOWLEDGE THAT WE
HEAR YOU- THAT- MS BERETTA AND
WE'VE ALREADY HEARD FROM HER
FATHER. AT A PREVIOUS HEARING
OF THE BEEN TRAVEL WORK THEY'RE
DOING- AND I DON'T WANT. I
DON'T LIKE THE FACT THAT
SOMETIMES WE CAST EVERYBODY IN
THE SAME LIGHT BECAUSE I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF FOLKS DOING
SOME GREAT WORK OUT THERE. WE
NEED TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WE
NEED TO ENCOURAGE IT WE NEED TO
INCENTIVIZE IT. AND WE NEED TO
SUPPORT IT. AND THAT'S A I
THINK THAT'S THAT'S THAT SHOULD
BE THE FUTURE OF HOW WE
APPROACH AGRICULTURE IN THE
STATE. THANK YOU THANK YOU SEND
THEM A REALLY APPRECIATE- THOSE
COMMENTS AND I AS WELL WANT TO
THANK THE PANEL FOR THEIR
PARTICIPATION THEIR COMMENTS
ALSO WANNA. ENCOURAGE MEMBERS
TO LOOK AT THE POLICY BRIEF
THAT WAS INCLUDED IN THE
INFORMATIONAL HEARING PACKET
FROM. YOU SEE A AND R. THAT
HIGHLIGHTS THE IMPACTS. OF THE
PREVIOUS DROUGHT ON SMALL SCALE
FARMERS AND ALSO. OFFERS POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS TO SUPPORT THEM
AND HELP THEM- THIS DROUGHT AND
SO THOSE ARE SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT I HOPE
THAT- WE CAN LOOK AT- AND
CONSIDER AS WE MOVE FORWARD AND
SO WITH THAT. I'LL TURN IT BACK
OVER TO CHAIR GARCIA- AS HE
WILL LEAD US IN THIS- LAST
PANEL. IT WAS RIDICULOUS
REVERSAL GOING TO THE THIRD AND
FINAL PANEL SOLUTIONS AND WHERE
WE GO FROM HERE. IF TWO
PRESENTERS- KAREN MICHEL. BALLS
FARMING COMPANY RULES FROM OF
MONGOLS DRAWFUL MELON AS LARA.
PROFESSOR FROM UC MERCED THEY
ARE WITH US. WILL NOT LASSEN
TO- TO BEGIN. I GUESS- I THINK
I'M GOING FIRST YEAR- THAT I
WANT TO- FOR START BY-
THINKING- THE CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR. AS WELL AS ALL THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- IT'S AN
HONOR TO BE HERE TODAY- AND
ALSO JUST TO BE ON THIS- PANEL-
WITH THIS WHOLE GROUP OF
DISTINGUISHED- PANELISTS- HOPE
EVERYBODY CAN. HEAR ME OKAY IF-
CAN'T CAN'T EXACTLY TELL WITH
THE IDEAS LOOKING WE CAN TELL
YOU THAT- OKAY PERFECT THANK
YOU- QUICK DISCLAIMER I DO LOOK
LIKE I'M SORT OF KICKED BACK
AND I HAVE TO BE- OF BEHEADED.
ANKLE SURGERIES IN MY ANKLE SB
ELEVATED SO I LOOK A LITTLE
MORE RELAXED THEN MAYBE I
SHOULD LOOK- AT THIS.
AUSPICIOUS OCCASION HERE BUT-
ANYWAY I DID WANT TO START- YOU
KNOW AGAIN EVERYBODY'S WE HAVE
A I HAVE A LONG DAY AND WE GOT
A LOT TO COVER IN TERMS OF
SOLUTIONS- AGAIN MY NAME IS
ZACH IS CANON MICHAEL. I AM
THE- THE PRESIDENT OF MY
FAMILY'S FARMING COMPANY ON THE
SIXTH GENERATION OF THE FAMILY
TO BE INVOLVED WITH THE
BUSINESS- WE'VE BEEN FARMING
THE SAME LAND HERE- OUTSIDE OF
LOS FINE YES- FOR THE- THE PAST
HUNDRED SIXTY YEARS- PLUS- WE
GROW- TWENTY DIFFERENT CROPS-
BOTH WITH ORGANIC AND
CONVENTIONAL METHODS. ARE
PRIMARILY- ANNUAL VEGETABLE
CROPS- I AM ALSO INVOLVED
ACTIVELY IN WATER ISSUES SERVE
ON OUR LOCAL WATER DISTRICT AND
I'M ALSO THE CHAIRMAN OF THE-
ST LOUIS AND ULTIMATE ON A
WATER AUTHORITY- WHICH- HAS-
TWENTY NINE- MEMBERS- COVERING
BOTH THE- OR COVERING ALL.
SECTORS ENVIRONMENT- WITH THE
GRASSLANDS BY WILDLIFE
MANAGEMENT AREA. COVERING
AGRICULTURE LARGE AND SMALL AND
ALSO- COVERING URBAN WATER USE-
VALLEY WATER AND SAN BENITO. SO
BEEN- INTERESTED IN WORKING
WITH A DIFFERENT SECTORS AND-
WANTED TO START JUST JUST VERY
QUICKLY WITH A QUICK STORY-
BECAUSE IT'S- L. ILLUSTRATIVE
IN MY MIND- I'VE BEEN ON THE-
TWITTER AND I POSTED A MAP THE
OTHER DAY AND WE DO A LOT OF
MAPS. HERE ON THE FARM AND WE
USE SPATIAL DATA SO I OF MY BIG
FAN OF MAPS TELL STORIES IN AND
LOOK AT THINGS AND OPPOSED A
MAP OF THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES DIVISION OF FLOOD
MANAGEMENT DOES A SACRAMENTO
SAN JOAQUIN RIVER SYSTEMS-
SCHEMATIC. AND IT ENDS UP
LOOKING A LITTLE BIT LIKE A
SUBWAY SYSTEM- IT SHOWS ALL THE
DIFFERENT- BOXES FOR THE
DIFFERENT RESERVOIRS AND THEIR
CAPACITIES AND THEN- JUST- THE
LIVE RIVERS END UP LOOKING LIKE
A TRANSIT LINES- AND SO THE-
REACTIONS WERE. A LOT OF PEOPLE
WERE INTERESTED IN AND- I
THOUGHT IT WAS- YOU KNOW. ABOUT
MAYBE SOME HADN'T SEEN. AND I
DID SEE ONE- AND NGO THE-
FRIEND THAT I KNOW THAT POSTED
YOU KNOW. HERE'S A LOOK AT- YOU
KNOW KIND OF THE OVER
ENGINEERING AND THE TERRIBLE
THE OVER THE YEARS YOU KNOW TO
THE RIVER SYSTEMS. AND I JUST
THINK THAT'S AN IMPORTANT PLACE
FOR ME ONE WHEN WE'RE THINKING
ABOUT SOLUTIONS AND THINKING
ABOUT WHERE TO START I THINK WE
DO NEED TO. KIND OF BE ABLE TO
HAVE TOUGH CONVERSATIONS AND BE
ABLE TO LOOK AT- AT SITUATIONS
IN AN OBJECTIVE. OBJECTIVE WAY-
YOU KNOW I THINK ALL OF US CAN
REACH FOR THE TAPPER OR THE
VAST MAJORITY CALIFORNIANS CAN
REACH FOR THE TOP MATTER WHERE
THEY ARE. IN THE- KIND OF
UNDERSTAND THAT- YOU KNOW.
WHAT'S GOING TO COME OUT AND
THEY RELY ON THAT AND- YOU KNOW
THEY THEY TRUST THAT AND- YOU
KNOW THAT. IN A LOT OF A- LOT
OF PLACES- OBVIOUSLY THE
MARKETS ARE ALSO FULL OF FOOD
AND SO WE DON'T WE DON'T WORRY
ABOUT ABOUT THOSE KIND OF
THINGS AND I THINK ALSO. PEOPLE
LIVE IN FLOOD PRONE AREAS AND
WHEN IT'S RAINING THEY DON'T
FEAR THE- FEAR THE FLOODS-
ANYMORE AND THINK A LOT OF
THAT'S BECAUSE WE DO HAVE AN
ENGINEERED SYSTEM- AND I THINK.
YOU KNOW. MAYBE WASN'T MAYBE
SOME OF THE DECISIONS THAT WERE
MADE. AND HOW THINGS WERE WERE
PUT TOGETHER- YOU KNOW DIDN'T.
ACCOUNT FOR. YOU KNOW
EVERYTHING OR OR YOU KNW
THERE'S- THERE'S OBVIOUSLY BEEN
SOME ISSUES WITH HAVING A
HIGHLY ENGINEERED SYSTEM BUT I
THINK AT LEAST WE NEED TO START
WITH. THE RECOGNITION THAT
SYSTEM GIVES US THE CALIFORNIA
THAT WE HAVE- YOU KNOW CANNOT
BE MANAGED BETTER CAN. WE DO
DIFFERENT THINGS YOU KNOW. WE
OF THE CAN BUT I WE ALSO TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE SOME
INVESTMENTS THE SYSTEM AND I
THINK THAT'S WHERE WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT SOLUTIONS. THERE
HAVE TO BE SOME INVESTMENTS
AND- TO BE HONEST I JUST FEEL
LIKE WE REALLY LAGGED BEHIND-
WE HAD POPULATION GROWTH AND
WE'VE HAD YOU KNOW. MASSIVE
CHANGE IN OUR STATE BUT NOT NOT
MUCH IN THE WAY OF. CHANGING
OUR WATER INFRASTRUCTURE- AND
YOU KNOW I THINK CALIFORNIA'S
VERY PROGRESSIVE STATE YOU KNOW
WE LEAD ON- CLIMATE CHANGE WITH
THE LEADERSHIP OF THE
LEGISLATURE WE READ ON. YOU
KNOW WANTING TO BE THE FRONT
RUNNERS IN- IN INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR. TRANSPORTATION FOR MODERN
TRANSPORTATION- I DRIVE BACK
AND FORTH FROM FRESNO TO LOS
BANOS QUITE A BIT AND- SEE THE
LARGEST CEMENT STRUCTURE GOING
ON ACROSS THE SAN JOAQUIN RIVER
THERE TO. TO SUPPORT- YOU KNOW
HIGH SPEED RAIL PROJECT- AND I
THINK THAT'S GREAT YOU KNOW IF
WE CAN WE CAN HAVE A PUBLIC
THAT'S WILLING TO SAY WILL VOTE
FOR. A HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS-
TO SUPPORT THAT KIND OF
INFRASTRUCTURE AYE I THINK THE
ONLY THING I HAVE A HARD TIME
WITH THIS. WHEN WE HAVE YOU
KNOW A FOUR BILLION DOLLAR-
WATER PROJECT THERE ARE YOU
KNOW THEY'RE LOOKED AT AS BEING
TOO EXPENSIVE. EVEN WHEN THEY
DO HAVE. DIRECT AND
DEMONSTRABLE BENEFITS FOR. THE
ENVIRONMENT AND FOR COMMUNITIES
AND FOR AGRICULTURE- YOU KNOW
THEY'RE STILL JUST LIKE THAT IS
THAT'S TOO MUCH BUT- YOU KNOW
AGAIN. WE DO HAVE THE WILL
POWER TO- PUT MONEY TOWARDS
VERY LARGE PROJECTS AND I THINK
YOU KNOW THE TIME HAS COME TO
WHERE YOU. NEED TO PUT SOME OF
THAT MONEY TOWARDS OUR- WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE. BECAUSE- WE ARE
LAGGING BEHIND WHEN I THINK
WHILE EVERYTHING IS ON THE
TABLE- YOU KNOW WE NEED
GROUNDWATER RECHARGE. WE NEED-
WATER MARKETS AND FLEXIBILITY
AND ALL THOSE KIND OF THINGS.
YOU KNOW ULTIMATELY THERE ARE
GOING TO NEED. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EARLIER REFERENCED YOU KNOW THE
NEED FOR SOME ADDITIONAL
INFRASTRUCTURE NINE AND I FEEL
LIKE THAT THAT'S TRUE THEIR
SMALL STREAM. PROJECTS THAT
NEED TO GET BUILT. THERE SOME
CAN BAN SAID NEEDS- CAPACITY
NEEDS TO BE RESTORED- YOU KNOW
WE CAN'T HAVE AN ACTIVE WATER
MARKET IF YOU CAN'T TRANSMIT
THE PRODUCT. AND WE CAN'T GET-
GROUNDWATER RECHARGE TO WORK
EFFECTIVELY YOU CAN'T MOVE THE
WATER INTO THE AREAS THAT ARE
APPROPRIATE RECHARGE. AND THEN
ALSO EXTRACT THAT WATER AT THE
SAME TIME AND MOVE IT TO WHERE
IT'S NEEDED AND IN TIMES OF
SCARCITY. SO AGAIN I THINK WE
NEED TO. WE NEED TO STEP BACK
WE NEED TO LOOK AT THAT THAT
THE CALIFORNIA THAT WE DO HAVE
TODAY- I THINK WE NEED TO VALUE
ALL THE DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDERS
I'M I'M A- I'M A CALIFORNIA
FARMER BUT- I AM- FIRMLY EIGHT.
A CALIFORNIANS FIRST AND
BELIEVE THAT. I CALIFORNIA'S A
WONDERFUL STATE THAT IT IS
BECAUSE THE COMMUNITIES THAT WE
HAVE BOTH- YOU KNOW LARGE AND
SMALL AND IN BETWEEN. IT'S A
WONDERFUL PLACE BECAUSE THE
ENVIRONMENT THAT WE HAVE. AND
IT'S A WONDERFUL PLACE BECAUSE
OF HAVING AGRICULTURE THAT WE
DO HAVE. AND HAVING AGRICULTURE
THAT OPERATES IN A HIGHLY
REGULATED ENVIRONMENT AND THAT
DOES CARE FOR WORKERS AND
WORKER PROTECTION AND- DOES
CARE FOR ENVIRONMENT
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION WITH-
YOU KNOW ENFORCEABLE PENALTIES
IF WE MAKE A- MAKE A MISTAKE.
AND I ALSO THINK IT'S A
MISTAKE- IN SOME WAYS I DO
THINK WE'RE GONNA HAVE
AGRICULTURE CHANGE WITH CIGNA.
AND I AND I DO AGREE THAT
SIGNAL WAS SOMETHING THAT WAS
NECESSARY. I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO BE HONEST AND IN
THOSE DISCUSSIONS I THINK WE
HEARD- WE'VE HEARD FROM A BUNCH
OF FAMILY FARMERS TODAY- WE'VE
HEARD SOME. ALLUSIONS TO OTHERS
THAT HAVE COME IN AND MAKE YOU
JUST SEE- CALIFORNIA AND
CALIFORNIA FARMLAND AS AS AND
NUMBER ON A SPREADSHEET
SOMEWHERE WITH THE- RETURN
PERCENTAGE ATTACHED TO IT AND-
YOU KNOW. I RAISE MY KIDS HERE
ON THE FARM. WE SUPPORTED OUR
COMMUNITY WE DONATE TO OUR
HOSPITAL TO OUR SCHOOLS- YOU
KNOW WE WALK THE SAME DEALS
WITH OUR WORKERS WE- YOU KNOW
WE'RE HERE DAY IN AND DAY OUT
AND THERE'S GROUPS OF PEOPLE
THAT HAVE VAST TRACTS OF LAND
THAT DON'T HAVE THAT SAME
CONNECTION TO OUR LANDS. AND I
THINK THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE
NEED TO BE HONEST ABOUT TALK
ABOUT THAT. YOU KNOW
AGRICULTURE IS GOING TO CHANGE
SEGMENT IS GOING TO CHANGE.
YOUR LIKE THIS YOU DO SEE THAT
THERE'S GONNA BE. A CONTRACTION
BUT I ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT EVEN THOUGH WE'RE IN THIS
TIME OF SCARCITY AND- YOU KNOW
IF YOU LOOK AT THE PAST DECADE
IT'S BEEN MORE DROUGHT YEARS
THAN THAN WHAT YEARS BUT- I
DON'T WANT TO TAKE OUR EYE OFF
THE FACT THAT. MAYBE WE. CAN DO
BETTER AND MAYBE WITH MORE MORE
COLLABO AND UNIT WITH EACH
OTHER MAYBE- PUTTING DOWN THE-
PUTTING DOWN SOME OF THE OLD
FIGHTS AND GRUDGES MAYBE WE CAN
WORK TOGETHER ON BETTER
SOLUTIONS ARE SOME GREAT
PROGRAMS GOING ON TO SUPPORT.
THE SHELF IN THE SACRAMENTO
VALLEY. I KNOW WE'RE LOOKING AT
PROJECTS HERE IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY TO. RESTORE THE
SAN JOAQUIN RIVER INTO MAKE-
IMPROVEMENTS HERE- I DON'T WANT
TO LOSE SIGHT OF THAT. YOU
KNOW. MAYBE IT MAYBE. MAYBE WE
CAN DO BETTER MAYBE YOU KNOW
THERE THERE ARE GOING TO BE
WHAT YEARS AGAIN THAT THERE ARE
GONNA BE. WAYS TO WORK TOGETHER
TO BABY RESTORE FISH
POPULATIONS BETTER THAN JUST
SUING EACH OTHER. MAYBE THE
SOLUTIONS LAY OUT ON THE GROUND
AND BY WORKING. TOGETHER WE GOT
INTELLIGENT PEOPLE WE'VE GOT.
MOTIVATED PEOPLE. AND THEY
WOULD BE A LOT BETTER OFF
PUTTING OUR ENERGY TOWARDS-
MAKING SOME REAL PROGRESS IN
TERMS OF DOING SOME PROJECTS
TOGETHER VERSUS JUST FIGHTING
EACH OTHER. AND JUST NOT THINK
THAT WE JUST HAVE TO GIVE UP.
YOU KNOW SO MUCH FARMLAND OR
GIVE UP SO MUCH- YOU HAVE
SPECIES TO GO EXTINCT I DON'T
THINK THOSE ARE THE- KIND OF
CONVERSATIONS I REALLY WANT TO
BE. A PART OF YOU KNOW I DO
LIKE I SAID EARLIER I THINK
SIGNAL IS GOING TO TAKE CARE OF
SOME OF THE UNSUSTAINABLE
THINGS. THAT HAVE BEEN
HAPPENING SO I'M FAIRLY
CONFIDENT IN IN THERE'S GOING-TO BE SOME CHANGE THERE BUT- I
THINK EVERY LOSS OF A
CALIFORNIA FAMILY FARM. IS A
HUGE LOSS FOR- NOT JUST
CALIFORNIA BEFORE THE NATION- I
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT AND
NOT JUST TALK ABOUT FOOD
SECURITY BUT NUTRITION SECURITY
BECAUSE THE KIND OF- THINGS WE
PRODUCE HERE IN CALIFORNIA WHAT
PEOPLE SHOULD BE EATING- YOU
KNOW YOU CAN HAVE A LOT OF
WHEAT OR CORN OR THOSE KIND OF
THINGS AND- THAT MIGHT BE
CALLED FOOD SECURITY BUT- YOU
KNOW HAVING. FRESH VEGETABLES
AND- YOU KNOW. THIRDS THAT
GIVES YOU KNOW NATURAL PROTEIN
AND ALL THOSE KINDS OF THINGS
ARE REALLY IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLE
AND- ALSO IS A HEALTHCARE ISSUE
IN A COSTUME. AND ALL THOSE
THINGS SO. ANYWAY YOU KNOW
THERE'S A MOTHER BASIC
SOLUTIONS I THINK YOU KNOW THE
WAY IT GRAVERT TALKS A LOT
ABOUT- YOU KNOW CUTTING THE
GREEN TAPE. AND GETTING
PROJECTS- STREAMLINED AND- YOU
KNOW WORKING THAT YOU KNOW
AGAIN MAKING THAT COLLABORATION
EASIER I THINK THOSE ARE REALLY.
IMPORTANT THINGS TO DO BUT-
AGAIN I JUST- APPRECIATE THE
TIME AND THINK THAT WE DO
POSITIVE PEOPLE WHO CAN WORK
TOGETHER AND- WE NEED TO
EMPOWER THEM AND POWER BETTER
WORKING RELATIONSHIPS AND- WORK
WITH THE- WITH THE LEADERSHIP
TO. TO KIND OF. GUIDE US
THROUGH. SOME OF THESE ISSUES
AND I THINK WE- ALL HAVE A
VESTED INTEREST IN MAKING
CALIFORNIA THE BEST IT CAN BE
FOR. FUTURE GENERATIONS AND I
THINK THAT'S THAT'S THE CHARGE
THAT I HAVE BEEN. THE WAY THAT
I'M TRYING TO WORK SO AGAIN
THANK YOU ALL FOR THE TIME I
APPRECIATE IT I KNOW IT'S BEEN
A LONG DAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERYMUCH AND- WE'LL GET BACK
TO YOU FOR. POTENTIAL QUESTIONS
WE HAVE ONE MORE PRESENTER
IT'S- A PROFESSOR MEDINA AS
LARA FROM UC MERCED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE INVITATION I.
REALLY HONORED TO SPEAK TO YOU-
I WOULD JUST GIVE YOU SOME
MAFIA NUMBERS ON ON THE OUTING
CALIFORNIA AND SOMETIMES- I'M
KIND OF IN THIS RELATIONS FINAL
BUT I FEEL REALLY HUMBLED BY
ALL THE TESTIMONY UPON MY
FELLOW- FINALLY SWITCH CAB. A
PROVIDE A GREAT CLOSER OF FIRST
ON ON THAT OUT AND HOW IT
AFFECTS US- OR- SO- SO IN IN
CALIFORNIA THERE'S ABOUT TWENTY
FIVE MEDIAN EXISTING FARMS
ABOUT. NINE POINT SEVEN ARE
REGULATED IN EVERY YEAR NEARLY
ONE POINT ONE MILLION ACRES
HE'S NORMAL FOLLOWING HIS
ROTATIONAL SIMPLY M<c.cyan> IF WE</c>
GET AN IDEA. THE SURVEY YOUR
INCREASES URINE SO IN THE
TWENTY TWELVE TWENTY SIXTEEN
THAT I WE SEE AN INCREASE OF
FIVE POINT FIVE- OR POINT SEEKS
A MEDIA NAY BECAUSE OAKLAND.
AND SO THAT'S WHAT THAT KIND OF
WORK WILL BE EXPECTING ANOTHER
OUR LADIES AND ALGOLD MODEL ON
THAT SO- HE NEVER SHOOK UP USES
THE IN THE STATE THAT THREE
POINT FIVE. HE COULD PUT THE
WATER. IN IN IN VERY THAT I
YEARS LIKE THESE THESE ARE
MILD. ECLIPSES. BECAUSE YOU'LL
NEED TO. YOU WAS ALWAYS A LOT
BEGIN A SECRETARY ROSS WHAT
MANY SHOULD THAT DO SO
EVERYTHING COUPON TO GROW THE
MOISTURE MOISTURE RETENTION IN
THE SOIL WE NEED TO PUT IN MORE
WHY WHEN YOU WHEN HE'S THE RIDE
SO YES- ACCESS THE WHY STRESS
WE ALSO KNOW THE YOU KNOW WATER
OR BOTH EIGHT IN THE WORST A
LONG PIECES WHY THAT HAS TO BE
IN WITH LAY AND ALSO LATER BY
ONE OF THE FINALLY THIS IS KIND
OF THE THIS ACCOUNT SO
GROUNDWATER THERE'S OUT IN THE
BOSTON TO THE AS YOU UNDER THE
INCLUDING TO THE ESTIMATED
THAT- EIGHT POINT SEVEN MEDIA
ON- EIGHT OF WITH THE- LOST IN
SURVEYS WHAT ARE WHAT ARE
REPLACED- TO GET A NET
REDUCTION OF GHOST DIGESTIBLE
TWO POINT SEVEN METER MAKE UP
WITH. SO THESE ARE ACTORS OF
ALL FOR THE IN THE HOUSE AND
ECONOMIC IMPACTS I CAN BE A
SUBSTANTIAL- AARON. I WAS
HEARING FROM THE LX TOOK A
VICTORY- THE SPEAKERS- KREIGER
WINTER POSTULANT AND ENFORCE
GROW PRICES. OF EACH GROUP
PRICES GET GREEDY ASTRAY AS
THE- THE SECTOR. ENDURING DROPS.
SO- WHAT IS THE ABOUT THESE
THREE TOLD YOU THAT OUT THE
RESULT IS IF IN INDIA'S ALL WE
HAVE THE NORTH AREA THAT YOU
SUPPLIED TO THE SADDAM VIRAL
STATE BRIAN WE SEEN ALL TO
ALMOST EVERY DAY WITH GOING TO
INTO THE INTO THE WILD- NEWS IN
IN THE AGAIN THE EARLIEST OF
SEEK BY OF ME THAT WE CAN THE
WE WATER THE ALL HOW MUCH WATER
YOU BOMBAY AND- KIND OF THE TO
GROUND BUT INTERESTING I PEOPLE
IN IN SOME SO WE HAVE A NOBODY
SHOULD BE ON THE ALL PRESENT BY
PER LAW THE BEGINNING AND- WE
HAVE A I THINK HE'S CONCERNED
ALSO ON ALL ON THAT I WILL SEND
RURAL COMMUNITIES AND SMALLER
WATER SYSTEMS. AND THIS IS
FORECASTER WESSEL DATED AND
LATER IN THE YEAR ND TURNED
OUT TO HAVE- A DECREASED AMOUNT
OF WHAT IT WAS EXPECTED TO
DONATE MY TV LICENCE THE WATER.
WILL BE THE NEW READY TO SEE
THE SENATE CULTURE AND
ENVIRONMENT ALSO THERE SO I GOT
IT WILL PUT THE FINISHING SO I
WAS SAYING- IF THAT IF YOU
THINK ABOUT IT THE ONLY ONE
INCH OR TWO INCHES OF WATER.
COOL IF YOU TRANSLATE THAT INTO
FIGHT NEED A NAY BECAUSE THEY
ARE TALKING ABOUT THAT A FULL
OF WATER BY THAT INCREASE IN
THE AMOUNT OF ONE OF THE YOU
NEED TO APPLY IT VIA IF THE
UNITS VERY. DIçN AND
PROFESSOR OF WHAT TO LOOK LIKE
YOU'RE SEEING. THEIR STATUS. AS
THE WITHOUT THE SOME OF INFORM
ABOUT SO THE YEAR WE LOOKING
LEAST TWO HUNDRED FIFTY TWO
HUNDRED NAY THOUSAND ACRES OF
FOLLOWED WILL ADD THAT IT'S OUR
REMOTE SENSING TO ME SO IN AND
CONCENTRATE IN OUR FIELD RICE
SO OF THE LOW LOWER BODY
PROTECTING GORDY'S WHAT WE ALSO
SEE A OF US SO MINDED WITH
SOMEBODY WILL THREE. IN THE ACT
CAN HAVE A HOW YOU GET GOING TO
BE BY SO THE HOUSE HAVE WILL
OLD ALSO GROUP IN HOW CHAIN
BECAUSE FORCE ACTION IN IN RE
FOR THAT ARE NEEDED SO IN THE
BY OUT WE HAVE CREATED. IT HE
IS A AND DONNA DAY LEGISLATION
ARE SUBJECTED ON WATER SYSTEM
PLAN I'M ONLY THIRTY- AROUND
WHAT I'M SORRY IF WATER
PROBABLY THE SENSE VALLEY
YOU'RE SO KEPT A NEW TO WITH
THE SCHOOL AND BODY DAY BUT
CONFLICT OF ALSO ENGINEERED
WATER SUPPLY FOR THE STATE SO
WE DON'T COVERED DOUG BUT I Y.
IS ARE BOTH IS ONE OF OUR WHAT
PERSON NEED TO BE PER THE
FLEXIBLE ALLOCATE OF WHAT YEAH
CAN ALSO DAMPEN THE EFFECTS OF
ALL OF THAT OUT IN THE ROOT OF
WHAT ISSUE STEMS AND THE SMALL
FARMERS ACOSTA- HE WAS SAYING
S. WEST- I REMARKABLE TO
DROUGHT AND ATTENTION SO WILL
BE TO THE IN BLUE WELL I THINK
BE FROM AVENUES RESEARCH
PROGRAM EMPLOY USE ONE YES- A
IS A JUST NEEDS GOING TO LAND
USE PROGRAM WE REALLY TO KNOW
ON GROUND IN OTHER REQUIRED
SOME UNSTABLE ON THAT CAN BE
DONE- MORE EACH YEAR NOW
THROUGH REMOTE SALES TEAM AND
PUT SYSTEM BOUNDARIES AND
PROGRAMS SO I ENCOURAGE. YOU.
TO KEEP THIS IN NOW IN INDIA OF
CONNECT APPROACH TO FORM WELL
SO WATER INFORMATICS PROGRAMS
TO PROTECT ACCOUNTING
FORECASTING MONITORING CAN PAY
OFF YOUR STUFF I MEAN- MORE
SENSORS MORE- PLACES THAT CAN
TELL US WHAT. IS STATUS OF THE
SMOKE I'VE GOT MORE FREQUENTLY
AND TIMELY AND ACCURATELY
SEARCH HELLO SOME OF PUSH INDIA
MARIINSKY BROUGHT TWENTY SOME
IS SOMETIMES ALSO ENCOURAGED
BOND ISSUE. FOR OPEN ACCESS
DATA AND MODELING PROGRAMS
WHICH OF THE ALBANY P. IT
INITIATE THE ABOUT THE- DOCTOR
PROVIDES INFORMATION ON ON A
CONSUMPTIVE USE SOME PROPS. AND
MIGHT ACTUALLY AGUIAR-CURRY
CHARGE IS A VERY PROMISING I
MEAN YOU ARE. TOLD ME- WATER
SUPPLIES IN JUST TO HAVE THAT
RESET OUR DURING FEATURES THAT
OUT ALSO AND INCORPORATION
X.-PEDITE- WATERMARK IS NOT OUT
LOW ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT IN
ALSO LOCAL- DISTRIBUTIONAL
IMPACTS BECAUSE OFTENTIMES YOU
THINK WATER FROM WONDER YOUNG
CREATING SOME ISSUES TO- SOME
OF THE- THE- COMMUNITIES THAT
LIVE THERE IN NESTS MORTAR.
FARMERS. YEAH ALSO- THE
BUNGALOW WHAT CLOSER BROWN GO
ALMOST EVERY IN KILEY HAS BEEN
GOING TO THE HIGH IF YOU WE
OPERATE ON THEIR FAVORITE WITH
THE THREE OF US ARE WITH THEM-
MICHAEL'S WHAT WAS SAYING
BATTERY HOW REGULATED
ENVIRONMENT FOR ANY CULTURE
AND- BUNDLING- WATER
CONSERVATION WE AT ALL THEN YOU
SHOULD BE IN SUCH AS THE SWEET
THE SWEEPER PROGRAM DISPLAY BY
STATED THAT HE ROLES ARE VERY
BENEFICIAL WE ARE GOES DOWN NOT
ONLY SAVING WATER SOLD SO
AVOIDING. A MASSIVE EXPANSION
TO NAY BUT WITH THOSE WATER
SAVING SO THOSE ARE THINGS THAT
ARE AVOIDED AND AT THE SAME
TIME- WE REDUCE EMISSIONS AND-
AND- BECOME MORE SUSTAINABLE
AND ON THE USE OF OUR
RESOURCES. LASTLY THIS IS A
GOOD OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW SAID
THEY SEE MY PROVISIONS IN THE
GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
PRACTICES KIND OF ON A STRESS
TEST TO SEE HOW- BOTH BEING-
MIGHT PLAY OUT IN FUTURE
DROUGHT BECAUSE THIS IS GOING
TO COME BACK- AND IN A FEW
YEARS. AND AND IT CAN WITHOUT I
WOULD LIKE TO- YESTERDAY CLOSE
MY REMARKS AND THINGS LIKE
GOING SENT USING THEIR SAY THAT
AND NOW AGAIN YEAH- THE
INVITATION. THANK YOU PROFESSOR
WE'RE GONNA ASK- COLLEAGUE
CENTER HERE IF THEY HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR ANY COMMENTS. AT
THIS TIME. SINGLE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS OF THE TO MY FELLOW
CULTURE. NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS- I OUR END THANK SO
MUCH BOTH YOU FOR. YOUR PRESS
SHE'S BEEN WITH THE AND THE
BODY AND- THE STATE THESE
IMPORTANT ISSUES GOING TO
ENGAGE THE MODERATOR AT THIS
TIME AND ASK IF- HE HAS A AN
ACCOUNT OF HOW MANY PEOPLE MAY
BE IN THE QUEUE TO SPEAK IN
PUBLIC COMMENTS. BEFORE WE
BEGIN THAT THEY WILL JUST LET
FOLKS KNOW THAT- WILL ALLOW
FOLKS TO SPEAK FOR ONE MINUTE.
AND DEPENDING ON HOW MANY FOLKS
ARE IN THE QUEUE IT COULD
POTENTIALLY BE LESSEN APATOW
MISTER MODERATOR EITHER THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT ON TODAY'S CALL YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU MADAM. MODERATOR.
AND CURRENTLY WE DO HAVE THREE
IN Q. THANK YOU. OUR FIRST
COMMENT COMES FROM LINE TWENTY
SIX LINE TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
TWENTY SIX MY INTENTION WAS TO
READ FROM A K<c.cyan> CRIME ARTICLE</c>
WATER AND DROUGHT IT FEATURES
MORE TO BE A POLICIES
CALIFORNIA LAWMAKERS CONTINUE
TO PERPETRATE WITH MY GENEROUS.
THIRTY SECONDS I JUST WANT TO
SCOLD YOU PEOPLE YOU ARE A JOKE
WE ARE WISE TO YOU DROUGHT ARE
ABSOLUTELY NORMAL WATER
POLICIES IS GOVERNMENTAL
FAILURE AND YOUR FAILING BIG
TIME JUST LIKE WITH THE FIRE.
JUST LIKE WITH THE EDT JUST
LIKE WITH EVERYTHING ELSE YOU
TOUCH YOUR DESTROYING
CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE ON TO YOU
AND YOUR LITTLE GAME BUT DON'T
TRY TO BLAME THE ALMOND
FARMERS. DON'T TRY TO BLAME
CLIMATE CHANGE OR WHATEVER
GARBAGE IS GOING TO COME OUT OF
YOUR MOUTH NEXT WE KNOW THAT
50% OF THE THINK WATER IS
ALLOWED TO FLOW OUT TO THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY TO THE PACIFIC
OCEAN. AND WE KNOW THAT YOUR
CORRUPTION IS GOING TO CATCH UP
WITH YOU BECAUSE CALIFORNIANS
ARE DONE THAT WILL RECALL NEWS-
WE CALL EVERY LAST PERSON IN
THE SUPERMAJORITY WE'VE HAD
ENOUGH. YOU DON'T CONSIDER
YOURSELF WARNED YOUR JOB ON THE
LINE OR DONE. WITHOUT YOUR
NONSENSE THANK YOU FOR ON THE
ONE MARK THE NEW SPEAKER PLEASE
MINING YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD YEAH THIS IS DAVE
BRUNSON- POLICY DIRECTOR WITH
CATHOLIC COMMUNITY THE FAMILY
FARMERS- WE SUBMITTED A LETTER
TO THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR ASKING FOR SUPPORT FOR
SMALL FARMERS IN THIS DROUGHT
CRISIS- WE VESTER SEVENTY
MILLION- TO HELP WITH THE WELL
SITUATION THAT DR DRIVE WELL
THERE'S- HUNDREDS OF- FARMERS
WHOSE WELLS ARE DRYING UP. AND
THAT THOUSANDS OF FARMERS WHO
WILL NEED TO LOWER THEIR PUMPS
AND THEIR WELLS. INVESTORS
FIFTEEN MILLION FOR- DROP THE
LEASE FUND- TO GO THROUGH CDFA
AND WE'VE ALREADY HAD TWO
HUNDRED FARMERS APPLY
PERSISTENCE FROM. OUR OWN
FARMERS MERCHANTS EACH CLIENT-
BUT THESE ARE SMALL GRANTS. AND
NOT REALLY A SUBSTITUTE FOR
STATE ASSISTANCE TO HELP SMALL
FARMERS SURVIVE THIS DROUGHT.
BUT WITHOUT STATE ASSISTANCE TO
LOCAL FOOD SYSTEM THE FARMERS
MARKET. WILL NOT BE THERE WHEN
THE DROUGHT ENDS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. TWO POINT SIXTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD THANK YOU GOOD EVENING
YEAH THANK YOU FOR CALLING THIS
HEARING TODAY THIS IS BRIAN
SHOW FOR THE CALIFORNIA CLIMATE
AND AGRICULTURE NETWORK AND I
KNOW IT'S LATE SO I'LL JUST
KEEP IT IF YOU PREFER COMING
FROM THE SPEECH PROGRAM WHICH
WE'VE BEEN ADVOCATING. FOR AND
TRACKING FOR. SIX YEARS NOW AT
FIRST WE SUPPORT THE CAN AND
THE FARMERS URGENT FOR DROUGHT
RELIEF FOR SMALL FARM.
INCLUDING EXPANDING THE SCOPE
AND INVESTMENT IN THE SPEECH
PROGRAM. INCLUDE WELL
MEDICATION FOR SMALL FARMS. WE
CAN KERRY NOT WITH WATER
EFFICIENCY IS A SMART MOVE
SECOND WE ALSO SUPPORT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS KIA AS RESENTED
COMMITTEE REPORT ON THE SPEECH
PROGRAM THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS
WHICH WERE DEVELOPED AND
APPROVED BY A COMMITTEE OF OVER
FORTY FARMERS TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROVIDERS YOUR CASE
NEXT BIRTH. WELL ACCELERATE
INNOVATION IN CIRCUS BROWN
LOTTERY D. BOB SAID THAT THE
EQUITY FOR UNDERSERVED FARMERS
AND REACHING THE STATE
INCLUDING THE DESERT REGION. I
THINK HEARD THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND STAFF TO REVIEW
THAT REPORT AS YOU LOOK FOR
ADDITIONAL SOLUTION TO THIS
CRISIS. THANK. YOU THAT COULD
BE YOU WELL NINE THIRTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE THIRTY YOU MAY BE ON MUTE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD YEAH THIS IS- DANTE
NORMALLY ME CAN YOU HEAR ME YES.
YEAH ALL RIGHT THE MANAGER AND
COUNSEL FOR THE CENTRAL GULF
THE WATER AGENCY AND THEN THE
SACRAMENTO SAN JOAQUIN
WATERSHED THE CENTRAL VALLEY
PROJECT IN THE STATE WATER
PROJECT BY THE MAJOR PLAYERS
AND WHAT IS HAPPENED IN THE
PAST IS A PATTERN AND PRACTICE
OF NOT PLANNING FOR SUBSEQUENT
YEARS BEING DRY AND THAT IS LED
TO THE COMPLETION OF THE STORE
WATER IN ADVANCE OF A DRY YEAR
LIKE WE HAVE TODAY AND THE
CREATION OF A REAL CRISIS BASED
ON A MISUNDERSTANDING OF THE
AVAILABILITY OF WATER THE WATER
PROJECTS WERE DEVELOPED FIVE
MILLION ACRE FEET BY THE YEAR
TWO THOUSAND FROM NORTH COAST.
THEY DIDN'T DO THAT SO THE
PROJECTS ARE WOEFULLY SHORT OF
WATER. IN A SHORTAGE IN THE
STATE IS HUGE IF WE CAN GET THE
PLANNING THE TAKE PLACE. TO
ACTUALLY UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
CAPABILITY IS GOING THROUGH A
SIX YEAR DROUGHT WHICH WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE PLANNED FOR THE
PROJECT. YEAH WE CAN GET ON A
STABLE PLATFORM IN ORDER TO DO
REAL PLANNING. WHAT WE HAVE NOW
IT'S AN ATTACK ON WATER RIGHTS
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. WOULD
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND NOTICES OF
CURTAILMENT GOING OFF FROM THE
STATE OR AND IT COULDN'T
SITUATIONAL ANTAGONISM. ANILINE
AND DIRECTION OF FAVORITISM
COURSE EXPORTS. ANYWAY WE NEED
SOME HELP TO GET BUT
MINISTRATION. BONTA ON A STABLE
PLAYING FIELD LIKE GREEN WITH
THE COMMENTS THAT WE NEED TO
WORK TOGETHER TO HELP SOLVE THE
REAL PROBLEM THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER JUSTIN UPDATE ON THE
NUMBER IN Q. WE DO HAVE FIVE IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANKS VERY
MUCH AND NINE TWENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TWENTY NINE THAT'S ME ALL RIGHT
HEY SO- THANK YOU PUBLIC
SERVICE FOR DOING WHAT YOU DO
I'M NOT HELPING YOU TO DO IT
BETTER. SANTA CLARA VALLEY AND
WHAT I'VE SEEN HERE WE INSTALL
THE HUGE I. IN ORDER TO TREAT
WATER WHICH MEANS CORPS MARBLE
HOWEVER. YOU CAN READ THE WAR
AT GREAT AND I WAS WONDERING
LAST YEAR WHAT THE HECK WAS
BUILT WHY ARE YOU TRAIN MORE
WATER IT'S NOT JUST FOR THE
FISH DOWNSTREAM UNDERSTAND
THAT. YOU WANTED IT YOU-
CONSERVE WATER BUT YOU DIDN'T
CONSERVE THE WATER THAT YOU HAD
ALREADY AND NOW YOU'RE COMING
BACK TO THE STATUS OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA IN YOU'RE SAYING
WE'RE GOING TO LIMIT YOUR WATER
SUPPLY AND ACCESS SO YOU CAN
EASILY GUARDING YOUR GREAT GIVE
ME. COMMANDOS IN YOUR BACK YARD
I THINK OUT WE HE'S BEEN THE
MONEY TO INSTALL MECHANISM THAT
LEADS WATER A LARGE FLOW IN
ORDER TO HOLD ON THE WATER AND
YOUR IF YOU AGING WITH THESE
CORRUPT OFFICIALS THAT ARE IN
THE WATER SYSTEM OUR EIGHTY
HALLWAY ALRIGHT AND THE WATER
AWAY AND NOW YOU WANT TO COME
BACK AND ASK FOR MONEY THIS
ISN'T ABOUT MONEY THIS IS ABOUT
HAVING SOME KIND OF FORESIGHT
INTO WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN AND
I'VE BEEN IN CALIFORNIA FOR MY
ENTIRE LIFE SO I'VE BEEN
THROUGH CAN DROUGHT. AND IT'S
GONNA HAPPEN NOT A DROUGHT
IT'S- AN OLD WATER YOU GUYS ARE
THANK YOU FOR DOING WHAT YOU DO
IT JUST DO IT BETTER THANK YOU
SLICE IT THANK YOU. NINE TWENTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING SHERIFF
GARCIA AND REINVESTMENT
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE BACK IN
MARKETS ON BEHALF OF AMERICA
ARE PLANNED TRAPS THANK YOU TO
BOTH COMMITTEES FOR FOCUSING ON
THIS IMPORTANT PUBLIC POLICY
MATTER. WELL YOU ARE FINALIZING
THE DETAILS ON THIS YEAR'S
DROUGHT PACKAGE WE URGE THAT
YOU SATISFIED FUNDING
SPECIFICALLY TO PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO FARMERS
AND RANCHERS AND CRITICALLY
OVER DRAFTED BASINS TO HELP
THEM MEET THEIR SICK MICHAEL.
THIS IS ESPECIALLY TRUE IN THE
CASE OF SOCIALLY DISADVANTAGED
SMALL FARMERS WHO DON'T HAVE
THE SAME RESOURCES AS FARMERS
THAT MAKES IT ON WATER PORTS
ARE BELONG TO LARGE COMMODITY
GROUPS. THEY NEED TO KNOW WHAT
INNOVATIVE PROGRAMS OR FARMING
AND RANCHING OPTIONS ARE
AVAILABLE TO THEM AND HOW TO
ACCESS THEM PRIOR TO DECIDING
TO FOLLOW THEIR PLANTS IT IS
IMPORTANT NOT ONLY TO THE
INDIVIDUAL LANDOWNER BATCH THE
VIABILITY FOR AGRICULTURE
ECONOMY AND OUR- STATE. SYSTEM
ADDITIONALLY WE ATHLETES
PROVIDE GREATER FUNDING FOR THE
HEALTHY SOILS PROGRAM IS TO BE
FOR ALL THE REASONS MANY OF THE
PANELISTS HAVE STEP INTO TODAY
AND FINALLY I WOULD JUST ADD
THAT A TEACHER SECRETARY ROSS
AND SHERMANESQUE ABOUT YOU THAT
GREATER COORDINATION WITH
FEDERAL RESOURCES ESPECIALLY TO
THE FARM CAL. IT'S AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR CALIFORNIA TO
ALIGN FUNDING AND TECHNICAL
SUPPORT TO ADDRESS CRITICAL.
DROUGHT INVESTMENTS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH BLIND FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD HELLO
YOU HEAR ME YES. HI HOW ARE YOU
MY NAME IS STEPHANIE I LIVE IN
A LITTLE LITTLE COMMITTEE- IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA HERE AS A
MATTER OF FACT THE SACRAMENTO
COUNTY- JUST TO GIVE YOU A
LITTLE TIDBIT ABOUT THAT DOES
HAPPEN WELL BUT MY OUTSIDE THAT
WE HAVE A LIVE OFF OF THE LAST
REGULAR WATER THERE'S FORTY SIX
HUNDRED RATEPAYERS. AREN'T
ADDITIONAL NOT LESS THAN A WEEK
THEY PASSED 210017% OVER THE
NEXT YEARS ON WATER BRINGING SO
MY HUSBAND I CAN AFFORD WE ARE
SMALL FARMERS WE CAN AFFORD TO
DRILL A WELL BUT NOW WE
UNDERSTAND THAT WATER RESOURCE
BOARD WILL COME ALONG HERE
WITHIN THE NEXT FIVE YEARS AND
BUT LEADERS BUT I'D LIKE TO
READ SOMETHING BECAUSE I'VE
BEEN FOLLOWING WATER FOR OVER
FORTY YEARS I'M THE FOURTH
GENERATION HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
SINCE. NINETEEN NINETY SIX
THERE HAS BEEN THE QUITE
MEASURES COME MONEY TO WATCH
ISSUE START THE TOTAL IS MORE
THAN TWENTY NINE BILLION
DOLLARS WHAT DO WE HAVE TO SHOW
FOR ALL THAT MONEY. NOT ONE.
THAT WOULD GET MORE WATER.
CALIFORNIA IS BASICALLY A DATA
AND WE ALL NEED TO KNOW THAT.
WITHOUT THEM COLLECTING RAIN
SNOWMELT FUNDAMENTAL INTENSIVE
AGRICULTURE. CALIFORNIANS WOULD
NOT EXIST. ALL THESE WOULD BE
BACK UP THERE PRESENT
POPULATION DESPITE DECADES OF
LONG DROUGHT NOT ONE. OF THE
TWENTY NINE BILLION DOLLARS AS
WILLING TO BUILD A NEW DAY OFF.
AT THE OFFICE THAT COULD HAVE
PROBABLY BEEN A DISASTER.
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE AND DOT
WHAT THE STATE DOESN'T EVEN
TAKE. CARE OF THE EXISTING
INSTEAD OF THE THAT WOULD
CAPTURE INSTALLED MORE ABOUT
QUESTIONS WHY HELLO GETS A BILL
ARGUE TWO SPECIAL INTERESTS
IMPORTANT OF IN PARK I THINK
TWELFTH WHILE LIKE A LITTLE BIT
THE FACT MIDDLESBROUGH AND I
THINK THAT HAVE NOTHING DO WITH
OUR STATE WATER ORGANS. OF THE
WATER IN OUR RIVERS JUST WANT
TO THE BUT OF I RIGHT RIGHT
BEING TO THE POLITICIAN THAT
HAS I THAT ARE SOME CURIOUS
ABOUT CONTROL BEING NOW THAT
HOUSE AB EIGHT AND THEN SB BY
FIVE BOB AND THAT'S WHAT I FIVE
STEEL DOORS ONE OF US THREE
HERE THAT IN HOT CLIMATE BACK
AND COUNTY YOU VER MUCH WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON THE SPEAKER.
LINE THIRTY ONE YOUR IS OF
PLEASE GO AHEAD EXISTENCE
LOCKED OUT BEHALF OF THE
COMMUNITY ALLIANCE FAMILY JUST
WANTED TO THE CHAIR THE MEMBER
CAN STAFF THEIR HARD FOR THIS
INFORMATION AND INSTRUCTIVE FOR
AND HEARING JUST WANTED TO
REITERATE HOW AT FOR MILLION
FOR INTEREST INCLUDING
ASSISTANCE WITH WELL THAT HE
HEARD FROM PREVIOUS COMMENT AND
ALSO POINT TO THE REC I COULD
ROSS TIßN OF SUSTAINABLE
FARMING AND OUR BUDGET ASK THE
REQUESTED WHICH WAS TO COMMIT
WHICH INCLUDES OF OUR DROUGHT
AFFECTS WAS EARLIER BROUGHT UP
BY DEFENSE THANK YOU SO MUCH
AGAIN. EVERYONE AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE TIME THANK YOU
OUR FINAL QUICK COMMENT COMES
FROM NINE THIRTY TO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK
YOU GOOD AFTER GOOD EVENING
MISTER DENNIS I'LL BE ON THE ON
BEHALF OF THE ALL THE LAUGHTER
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION COOPER GREEN IF HE
SEVERAL OTHER AGRICULTURAL
ORGANIZATIONS- VIRTUAL WEEK
COMMEND. GARCIA AND RIVAS FOR
HOLDEN HEARING HOUNDS
CONVERSATION ABOUT DROUGHT THE
CHALLENGES THAT THE CALIFORNIA
FARMERS AGRICULTURE INFECTED
THE WHOLE STATE OF STACY. WELL
WE DO SUPPORT OF MUCH IN THE
DROUGHT WATER PACKAGE THAT HAS
BEEN DISCUSSED. OVER THE BUDGET
OF SYSTEM THAT WE'VE HAD THIS
YEAR- INCLUDING THIS WEEK
FUNDING WE- WE WANT TO DO
INCREASE INVESTMENTS IN STIGMA.
IMPLEMENTATION AND THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT ASPECT TO THE NEXT
COMING TWO YEARS THAT WE
SUPPORTED LOCAL WATER SUPPLY
LIABILITY PROGRAM SUCH AS CLEAN
WATER WATER RE USE CLEAN
DRINKING WATER EVEN PEOPLE OF
CLEANUP WILL HELP PUT MORE
WATER IN THE SYSTEM IMMEDIATELY
FOR OUR DRINKING WATER.
AVAILABILITY WE REALLY DO NOT
WANT TO LOSE THE FOCUS SO WHERE
WILL BE TO INCREASE WATER
SUPPLY SITES RESERVOIR IS A
GREAT EXAMPLE THERE'S FUNDING
AVAILABLE FOR IT AND WE SHOULD
CONSIDER WAYS TO EXPEDITE THAT-
THAT PROJECT AND THE
OPPORTUNITIES UP FOR THE
PROJECT. AND THEN FINALLY I A
PROJECT- CHAIRMAN ESCOBAL THE
COMMENT ON THE WATER RIGHT OUR
SYSTEM WE ACTUALLY SUPPORT-
MAINTAINING THE CURRENT WATER
RIGHT SYSTEM METHOD IS NOT THIS
IS THE TIME CAN BE TRULY WATER
RIGHTS BECAUSE IN TIMES OF
SCARCITY THAT'S WHEN WE USED
THE SYSTEM TO DETERMINE. YOU
KNOW WHERE THERE'S APPROPRIATE
REDUCTIONS THE NECESSARY
REDUCTIONS IN SUPPORT THAT
SYSTEM GOING FORWARD AND WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THAT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME WE
APPRECIATE THE. OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY TODAY. THANK YOU THERE
ARE NO COMMENTS IN THE QUEUE AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU SO MUCH
WE'RE GOING TO CLOSE PUBLIC
COMMENTS NOW AND- ASK IF ANYONE
HERE ON THE FLOOR AS ANY
CLOSING REMARKS MISTER NO
CLOSER MARCHES APPRECIATE AGAIN
STAFF ALL THE WORK- IN THE
PREPARATION OF THIS
INFORMATIONAL HEARING
APPRECIATE- YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND LOOK FORWARD TO THE FOLLOW
UP- FROM THIS YEAR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH C. AND ALL OTHER
REQUESTS TO SPEAK I. TWO ONE
GRATEFUL TO THE STAFF. TEAM TO
PUT THIS TOGETHER ALL THE
QUESTIONS OF THE PANELISTS. ALL
THOSE WHO HAVE CALLED IN. TO
SHARE THEIR PUBLIC COMMENTS AND
THAT WE DEFINITELY HAVE SOME
WORK TO DO AND TO FOLLOW UP SO
WITH THAT. WE WILL ADJOURN THIS
MEETING.